It's nearly 2:00 in the afternoon when we reach Jennifer's family's apartment, and she's just gotten up. She's still eating a very late breakfast.
我们到达珍妮弗家公寓时已是下午两点近了，她才刚刚起床。她还在吃一份非常晚的早餐。
I'll finish my noodles, then I'll start packing.
我吃完面条就开始收拾行李。
I'm with my co-worker, Emanuele Berry, and we're in a quiet working-class neighborhood in the part of Hong Kong that's called New Territories. It's a Sunday, so Jennifer is getting ready to do what she does every weekend-- what she did yesterday, in fact. That's why she slept late. She's going to a protest-- with a little backpack.
我和同事埃曼纽尔·贝里在一起，我们正位于香港新界一个安静的工人阶级社区。今天是星期天，所以珍妮弗正准备做她每个周末都会做的事情——事实上她昨天也做了。这就是她睡懒觉的原因。她要去参加抗议活动——背着一个小背包。
So this is the bag that I usually bring.
这就是我通常带的包。
So this is a maroon bag.
这是一个褐红色的包。
It's a very small one. We have to keep everything light. So I always have a bottle of water and then many tissues. I have to bring a lot of tissues because we need to wipe our eyes when there is tear gas. And because I know how to do first aid, I always bring my first aid kit.
这是一个非常小的包。我们必须让一切保持轻便。所以我总是带一瓶水和很多纸巾。我必须带很多纸巾，因为当有催泪瓦斯时我们需要擦眼睛。而且因为我会急救，所以我总是带着我的急救箱。
The first aid kit is a little zip-up bag with roller bandages and gauze and gloves and stuff to sterilize a wound. Jennifer started at the volunteer ambulance corps in seventh grade and has used all this stuff at demonstrations. She packs her wallet and her AirPods.
急救箱是一个小拉链包，里面有卷带、纱布、手套和消毒伤口的东西。珍妮弗在七年级时就加入了志愿者救护队，并在示威活动中使用过所有这些装备。她装上了钱包和AirPods。
Because I have to listen to songs.
因为我必须听歌。
Two batteries for her phone because she's on it constantly during protests, checking the continuously updated online maps that show where the police are and show escape routes. She packs a black T-shirt. The uniform of the Hong Kong protesters is black shirt, black pants, surgical masks to disguise their identities.
她带了两块手机电池，因为在抗议期间她不停地使用手机，查看持续更新的在线地图，了解警察的位置和逃生路线。她带了一件黑色T恤。香港抗议者的制服是黑衬衫、黑裤子，以及用来隐藏身份的医用口罩。
Jennifer, by the way, is not her real name. But for the bus ride to the protest, she doesn't wear her uniform. She wears a striped maroon shirt.
顺便说一下，珍妮弗不是她的真名。但在去抗议现场的巴士上，她没有穿制服。她穿了一件条纹褐红色衬衫。
Yeah, I wear a normal T-shirt when I go out so that no one can identify I am going to protest. And sometimes I bring makeup so that I can transform myself after the protest.
是的，我出门时穿普通的T恤，这样没人能认出我是要去参加抗议。有时我会带化妆品，这样抗议结束后我可以变换一下形象。
I don't understand. How do you transform yourself? Like, what's the--
我不明白。你如何变换形象？比如，什么——
I bring foundation-- very small, but can do everything.
我带了粉底——非常小，但什么都能做。
How different are you going to work with that foundation?
那用粉底去上班会有什么不同吗？
No, it looks like you're not going to protest. Because girls who are going to protest, they barely do makeup. But if girl is doing makeup, they're probably meeting someone. And so I bring this one. And then of course, I bring my brow pencil because it really can make you look like another person.
不，那样看起来就不像是去抗议了。因为去抗议的女孩几乎不化妆。但如果女孩化妆了，她们可能是在见什么人。所以我带了这个。当然，我还会带上眉笔，因为它真的能让你看起来像另一个人。
Eyebrows are very important, I agree.
眉毛很重要，我同意。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] And I bring lipstick. Sorry, it's a very small room.
是的。（笑）我还带了口红。抱歉，这房间太小了。
So we're in your room. Your room has pink walls, and there is a bunk bed with the bed on the top and a desk underneath it.
我们现在在你的房间里。你的房间有粉色的墙壁，还有一张上下铺的床，上面是床，下面是书桌。
Yeah, it's very typical Hong Kong girl's room.
是的，非常典型的香港女孩房间。
For a Hong Kong protester to live at home with her mom and dad, that is not unusual in any way. If you know anything about the demonstrations that have overtaken Hong Kong since June, you know it's mostly young people in the city where rents are high. Jennifer is 22 and just graduated college. She's working her first entry-level job at a public relations firm.
对于一个香港抗议者来说，和父母住在一起并不罕见。如果你对自六月以来席卷香港的示威活动有所了解，你就会知道那大多是租金高昂的城市里的年轻人。珍妮弗22岁，刚大学毕业。她在一家公关公司从事第一份初级工作。
I came to Hong Kong because there were things about the protests that I really did not understand, and we'll get to that. But one of the things that fascinated me once I arrived was learning what a routine the protests have become and what that was like for the people in them. This was mid-September, the 13th week of protests for Jennifer.
我来到香港是因为抗议活动中有些事情我真的不理解，我们稍后再谈。但我抵达后最着迷的一件事是了解抗议活动已经变得多么规律，以及这对参与其中的人意味着什么。当时是九月中旬，这是珍妮弗参与抗议的第13周。
I'm not really worried because it's just like another day. I think I will meet up with two friends of mine. But I'm not sure if I am going to because they are couples so I don't want to be-- [LAUGHS] they are couple, so I don't want to be-- they always kiss next to me. So, mm, yeah.
我并不担心，因为这就像是平常的一天。我想我会和我的两个朋友见面。但我还不确定会不会去，因为他们是情侣，我不想成为……（笑）他们是情侣，所以我不想成为……他们总是当着我的面亲吻。所以，嗯，是的。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃响）
Oh.
噢。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Speak of the devil, it's her friend, the one who kisses your boyfriend at demonstrations. And she's calling with bad news. She was going to bring gas masks to the rally today. They'd order them from Amazon, Jennifer thinks. But now she's learned that bringing gas masks would be a bad idea. Because at the subway station--
说曹操曹操就到，是她的朋友，那个在示威中会亲吻男朋友的家伙。她打来电话带来了坏消息。她本打算带防毒面具去今天的集会。珍妮弗认为他们是从亚马逊订购的。但现在她得知带防毒面具是个坏主意。因为在地铁站——
Police are searching everybody, including men, little ones, and young people like us. They're sharing their bags. And if they have any equipment with them like the gas mask, eye mask, whatever, they just arrest them, yeah. So my friend just asked me if it is a must for me to get the gas mask, so I told her that no, it is not a must. I don't want to risk my friend getting searched. So she told the other friend not to come out with equipment.
警察在搜查所有人，包括男人、小孩和像我们这样的年轻人。他们在搜查包。如果他们携带任何装备，比如防毒面具、眼罩之类的，他们就会直接逮捕他们。所以我的朋友刚才问我带防毒面具是不是必须的，我告诉她不是必须的。我不想冒险让我的朋友被搜查。所以她告诉另一个朋友不要带着装备出来。
Not ideal, but she's gone without gas masks before. Jennifer grabs her knapsack, says bye to her mom, who tells her to come home early, a request that will be totally ignored. And we head outside. But then she turns and runs back.
虽然不理想，但她以前也曾不带防毒面具参加过抗议。珍妮弗抓起她的帆布包，和妈妈告别，妈妈让她早点回家，但这个要求被完全无视了。我们走向外面。但随即她转身跑了回去。
What did you forget?
你忘了什么？
Umbrella. It is very important to have umbrella.
雨伞。带雨伞非常重要。
Even if it's not going to rain?
即使不会下雨吗？
Yeah, it is not for the rain. It is for tear gas and bullets.
是的，这不是为了防雨。这是为了防催泪瓦斯和子弹。
Rubber bullets, that is.
你是说橡皮子弹。
It works on bullets?
它对子弹有效吗？
Yes. Frankly, yes. No, no, I don't understand why, but always, those bullets, they slip off along the umbrella edge. So they just-- they don't get through the umbrella.
是的，坦白说，是的。不，不，我不明白为什么，但总是这样，那些子弹会顺着伞沿滑开。所以它们……它们穿不透伞。
Also, protesters hide behind a wall of umbrellas when they're painting graffiti or dismantling a closed-circuit TV camera on the street, doing anything else they don't want the police to see.
此外，抗议者在街上涂鸦或拆除闭路电视摄像头，或者做任何不想让警察看到的事情时，会躲在伞墙后面。
As she and I and Emanuele head to the bus stop, we notice other young people carrying full-sized umbrellas on this totally sunny day.
当她、我和埃曼纽尔前往巴士站时，我们注意到其他年轻人在这阳光明媚的日子里也带着全尺寸雨伞。
Walking over here to the bus, are you looking around to see if-- other people you think are going to protest?
走去巴士的路上，你会四处看看是否有……你也认为要去抗议的人吗？
Yeah, you always want to know how many people are around you, right? Yeah.
是的，你总是想知道周围有多少人，对吧？是的。
OK, and so there's some young people on our left, two people standing next to you.
好的，左边有几个年轻人，站在你旁边的两个人。
I think the girl probably is not because she brings a very small bag. But the tall guy, the tall guy in white shirt.
我想那个女孩可能不是，因为她带了一个很小的包。但那个高个子，穿白衬衫的高个子。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Yeah, and then the couple behind you, probably.
是的，还有你身后的那对情侣，大概是吧。
It's like, are you on my side? Are you one of us? Once you're at the protest, everybody's in a mass so you don't really know who's on your team. Here in the neighborhood, it's kind of exciting to wonder who your allies might be.
这就像是，你是站在我这边的吗？你是我们的一员吗？一旦到了抗议现场，所有人都在人群中，你真的不知道谁是你的队友。在这里的社区，猜测谁可能是你的盟友其实有点兴奋。
The protests in Hong Kong have been international news for months, kicked off by people's fears that mainland China is threatening some very basic things about their city and their lives. But for all the coverage, here at our show, we felt like we weren't seeing many stories where we got to know anybody very well-- who they were, what exactly they expected was going to come out of the protests, given China's intransigence.
香港的抗议活动几个月来一直是国际新闻，起因是人们担心中国大陆正威胁着他们城市和生活中一些非常基本的东西。但尽管有各种报道，我们节目组觉得我们并没有看到多少能让人深入了解这些人的故事——他们是谁，考虑到中国政府的强硬态度，他们到底期望从抗议中得到什么。
Three of us arrived in Hong Kong in mid-September, me and Emanuele and a co-worker, Diane Wu. I have to say, one of the things that was fascinating, given the ugly state of democracy here in the United States lately, was to be among so many young people who believe so intensely in democratic ideals and yearn so deeply for the basics, like normal elections and free speech and free assembly.
我们三人于九月中旬抵达香港，包括我和埃曼纽尔，还有一位同事戴安·吴。我必须说，鉴于美国最近糟糕的民主状况，能身处这么多如此强烈地信仰民主理想、如此深切地渴望基本权利（如正常的选举、言论自由和集会自由）的年轻人中间，是一件令人着迷的事情。
Though, just in the last few weeks since we got to Hong Kong, we've watched the situation change dramatically. It's gotten much more violent, harsh new measures by the government.
尽管在我们抵达香港后的几周里，我们目睹了局势的急剧变化。它变得更加暴力，政府采取了更严厉的新措施。
This hour, we have the story of the change that we witnessed and what we think it might mean. If you haven't been following this story at all-- maybe you've been sitting this one out-- we're going to catch you up on what you need to know. We have all sorts of people from all sides of this that we want you to meet. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. This week, overseas with a lot of people who have some very American values. Stay with us.
这一小时，我们将讲述我们所见证的变化以及我们认为它可能意味着什么。如果你根本没有关注这个故事——也许你一直置身事外——我们将为你补齐你需要知道的内容。我们想让你认识来自各方的各种各样的人。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。本周，我们将与许多有着非常美国价值观的人一起，在海外报道。请继续收听。
Act One, The Cursed Generation. OK, so what politicized thousands and thousands of people this much, that they've dropped their normal lives, and they're coming out every single weekend to protest? It's now been 18 straight weeks.
第一幕：被诅咒的一代。好吧，到底是什么让成千上万的人如此政治化，以至于他们放弃了正常生活，每个周末都出来抗议？现在已经连续18周了。
Take Jennifer, for instance. She's somebody who worked at Abercrombie and Fitch during college. She told me on the bus to protest that's why her English is so good. She's somebody who wanted to be a singer. Actually got a chance to go pro when she was 16, but her mom quashed that, saying it was too much of a long shot and she should get an education and get a normal job. Jennifer was actually very surprised when I informed her that an American parent might have said the same exact thing.
以珍妮弗为例。她大学时曾在Abercrombie and Fitch工作过。她在去抗议的巴士上告诉我，这就是为什么她的英语这么好。她曾经想成为一名歌手。事实上，她在16岁时有机会成为职业歌手，但她妈妈否决了，说那成功的几率太渺茫，她应该接受教育并找一份正常的工作。当我也告诉她美国父母可能会说完全一样的话时，珍妮弗感到非常惊讶。
Oh, I thought American dreams can be true, something like that, because I watched Glee.
噢，我以为美国梦可以成真之类的，因为我看了《欢乐合唱团》。
So how did this Glee-watching, internet-savvy college grad in her first office job, how did she end up protesting in the street every weekend with tens or-- I don't know-- maybe it's hundreds of thousands of her peers? Well, for starters, Jennifer's 22, which means she's part of a special generation in Hong Kong.
那么，这个看《欢乐合唱团》、精通网络的大学毕业生，在第一份办公室工作期间，是如何最终每个周末都走上街头，与成千上万甚至……我不知道……可能是几十万同龄人一起抗议的？首先，珍妮弗22岁，这意味着她是香港特殊一代的一员。
I'm born in Hong Kong in 1997, right before the handover.
我出生在1997年的香港，就在回归之前。
And here's a protester we're calling Alice.
这是我们称之为爱丽丝的抗议者。
And I'm born in 1997.
我出生于1997年。
Here's her friend we're calling Tiffany.
这是她的朋友，我们称之为蒂芙尼。
I'm also born in 1997.
我也出生于1997年。
You can call me Yuen, and I'm born in 1997.
你可以叫我媛，我也出生于1997年。
So 1997 is the year when Hong Kong was handed over back to China from the British.
所以1997年是香港从英国交还给中国的年份。
OK, let's just pause on these 22-year-olds for a minute for some quick history. As you may or may not know, Hong Kong sits on the edge of mainland China, right? It was a British colony for a really long time, starting in the 19th century. And then finally, in 1997, the British got out. They handed it over to China. And the idea was, there's going to be a 50-year transition period. After 50 years, China would fully be in charge. But during that 50 years, Hong Kong would be a democracy.
好了，让我们为这些22岁的年轻人暂停片刻，回顾一下历史。如你所知或不知道，香港位于中国大陆的边缘，对吧？它在19世纪开始是一个英国殖民地。最后，在1997年，英国人撤离了。他们把它交还给了中国。当时的设想是有一个50年的过渡期。50年后，中国将全面掌管。但在那50年里，香港将是一个民主社会。
Now, Hong Kong people are to run Hong Kong.
现在，香港人要治理香港。
That's the last British governor of Hong Kong during the handover ceremony in 1997.
这是香港最后一位英国总督在1997年交接仪式上的讲话。
That is the promise, and that is the unshakeable destiny.
这是承诺，也是不可动摇的命运。
But to be clear, Hong Kong had not been a democracy under Britain. But they were going to transition towards it over a bunch of years. And the hope was, after 50 years, in 2047, the Chinese government would let them stay a democracy-- which, at the time, did not seem like a crazy idea.
但需要明确的是，香港在英国统治下并没有实现民主。但他们将在多年里逐步向民主过渡。当时的愿望是，50年后的2047年，中国政府会让他们继续保持民主——这在当时看来并不疯狂。
China was opening up in all kinds of ways, though it wasn't clear how this was going to play out. And at the end of the day, after 50 years, in the year 2047, China was going to be able to do whatever it wanted in Hong Kong. These are the children born the year that clock started ticking.
中国正在以各种方式开放，尽管尚不清楚这一切会如何发展。终究，50年后的2047年，中国将能够在香港做任何它想做的事。这些孩子出生在那个时钟开始走动的那一年。
And have you heard of the phrase "cursed generation?"
你听说过“被诅咒的一代”这个词吗？
Yes, it was a joke among the 1997 people.
是的，这是97后之间的一个笑话。
It was pretty much a joke, pretty much a funny thing to us, because--
这几乎是个玩笑，对我们来说几乎是一件好笑的事，因为——
I think when we first joke about it, it's really primary schools, but--
我想我们第一次开这个玩笑是在小学时，但——
The cursed generation is just what we've been joking around for all those years.
被诅咒的一代只是我们多年来开玩笑的话题。
Originally, the joke had to do with a coincidence. They were cursed because of some weird, bad luck during some big childhood milestones they all went through together, like the year of their kindergarten graduation, the SARS virus hit Hong Kong. And the city shut down, graduations were canceled.
最初，这个笑话与巧合有关。他们被诅咒是因为他们一起经历的一些童年重大里程碑时出现了一些奇怪的坏运气，比如在他们幼儿园毕业那年，非典病毒袭击了香港。城市关闭了，毕业典礼被取消了。
Six years later, when they should've had their elementary school graduation, same thing happened again, but with swine flu. And Jennifer remembers that her friends joked that when they graduated high school, it was going to be Ebola. And that's when they started using the word "cursed."
六年后，当他们本该小学毕业时，同样的事情再次发生，只不过是猪流感。珍妮弗记得她的朋友们开玩笑说，当他们高中毕业时，将会是埃博拉病毒。就在那时，他们开始使用“被诅咒”这个词。
I think that was around the time that JK Rowling wrote Harry Potter and the Cursed Child. Yeah, so many of us-- oh, we're the cursed child. Or we say that we are the chosen one because Harry Potter was the chosen one. All of us love Harry Potter.
我想那大约是JK·罗琳写《哈利·波特与被诅咒的孩子》的时候。是的，我们很多人——哦，我们是被诅咒的孩子。或者我们说我们是被选中的人，因为哈利·波特是被选中的人。我们所有人都喜欢哈利·波特。
So we always think that, oh, we are the chosen one. We have to face something special in our life. Or we are the cursed one. We have to face something bad or face something significant.
所以我们总是想，哦，我们是被选中的人。我们的生活中必须面对一些特殊的事情。或者我们是被诅咒的人。我们必须面对一些糟糕的或重大的事情。
Jennifer says the "chosen one" side of things didn't really kick in until their senior year of high school. It was 2014. They were 17, the 17th year since the handover. And that year, people in Hong Kong were still expecting that mainland China was going to let them start holding full-on elections, where they could choose their own leaders, as promised back in 1997. And that year, China announced it wasn't going to happen.
珍妮弗说“天选之人”的想法直到他们高三才真正产生。那是2014年。他们17岁，是回归后的第17年。那一年，香港人仍然期待中国大陆会让他们开始举行全面选举，让他们可以选择自己的领导人，就像1997年承诺的那样。而那一年，中国宣布这不会发生。
This led to a movement called the Umbrella Movement, headed by young people, teenagers, who'd learned their politics in these public school classes that all these 22-year-olds talk about as being instrumental in their thinking, classes that began as part of the handover called Liberal Studies classes that explained, among other things, the promises of 1997 and the rights of Hong Kong citizens.
这导致了一场名为“雨伞运动”的运动，由年轻人和青少年领导。他们在这些公立学校的课程中学习政治，所有这些22岁的人都谈到这些课程对他们的思维至关重要，这些被称为通识教育的课程始于回归，其中解释了1997年的承诺和香港公民的权利等内容。
They took to the streets, most of them for the first time, demanding to vote, carrying umbrellas, thousands of people in a vast procession down the streets in a protest movement that was almost entirely peaceful. And they lost. They didn't get the vote. After three months, the protests ended.
他们走上街头，其中大多数人是第一次，要求投票权，打着雨伞，成千上万的人在街头进行了一场几乎完全和平的抗议游行。但他们失败了。他们没有得到投票权。三个月后，抗议结束了。
Alice works for a multinational company in an entry-level job out of college. She's a management trainee. She says she went to some protests back then out of solidarity with her peers.
爱丽丝大学毕业后在一家跨国公司从事入门工作。她是一名管理培训生。她说她当时参加了一些抗议活动，是为了声援同龄人。
I was just amazed by the other students.
我只是被其他学生震惊了。
But she did really get all the politics. That changed this June, when Hong Kong introduced the bill that would allow mainland China to extradite people from Hong Kong to be tried and punished in China under Chinese law. This was seen as a new and very menacing encroachment on the rights of Hong Kong citizens.
但她确实理解了所有的政治。这在今年六月发生了变化，当时香港引入了一项法案，允许中国大陆将嫌犯从香港引渡到中国，根据中国法律进行审判和惩罚。这被视为对香港公民权利的一种新的、非常具有威胁性的侵犯。
Since 1997, they'd been ruled by Hong Kong laws and Hong Kong courts, where everybody is presumed innocent with the rights we know in most democratic countries. Now, anybody could get thrown into the prisons and courts of communist China.
自1997年以来，他们一直受香港法律和香港法院管辖，每个人都被推定无罪，享有我们在大多数民主国家所知道的权利。现在，任何人都有可能被扔进共产主义中国的监狱和法院。
I would say that that was the time when I first feel awakened, when I'm truly understanding what's happening when I first go to the march of the no extradition bill. And I was very, very emotional at that time because there is only around 7 million people in Hong Kong. But 1 million walk on the street with the same demand, with the same wish of having Hong Kong to remain its current state.
我想说，那是我第一次感到觉醒的时候，当我真正理解了当我第一次去参加反引渡法游行时所发生的事情。当时我非常、非常激动，因为香港只有大约700万人。但有100万人走上街头，怀着同样的诉求，同样的愿望，希望香港保持现状。
Wanting Hong Kong to stay like it is with its own laws, separate from China. A week later, 2 million people came out.
希望香港保持现状，拥有自己的法律，与中国分离。一周后，200万人走上街头。
At the time, I was feeling very, oh my god, this is so touching. Why is people so united? And then the next second, the government just declares that, oh, we heard your voice, but we will be continuing on the bill on Tuesday. So that was a really big contrast.
当时，我感觉，天哪，这太感人了。为什么人们如此团结？然后下一秒，政府就宣布，哦，我们听到了你们的声音，但我们将在周二继续推动该法案。这形成了一个巨大的对比。
And in the morning, you see how peaceful things were. But at night, you see the police coming out and start brutally hitting people. It was really unforgettable to me because that was the first time when I witnessed with my real eyes that the police is chasing people. They are chasing students who did not do anything and start to beat them and arrest them.
早上，你看到事情是多么和平。但到了晚上，你看到警察出来开始残酷地殴打人们。这对我来说真的很令人难忘，因为那是我第一次亲眼目睹警察在追赶人们。他们在追赶那些什么都没做的学生，开始殴打并逮捕他们。
Other 22-year-olds also told us how radicalizing it's been to see police teargassing and beating peaceful protesters. And at this point-- I didn't understand this before we got to Hong Kong-- a lot of the emotion driving the protests is just about the police.
其他22岁的年轻人也告诉我们，看到警察使用催泪瓦斯和殴打和平抗议者是多么激进。此时此刻——我在来香港之前并不了解这一点——抗议活动背后的大部分情绪其实都与警察有关。
Because the government is supporting them to do such things, and there is no penalty for them, even if they are doing things that are completely unacceptable to everyone.
因为政府支持他们做这样的事情，即使他们做的事情对每个人来说都完全不可接受，也没有任何惩罚。
Of course, nobody knows where this is going to lead by 2047, when China fully takes over Hong Kong. But for Jennifer and lots of other people her age, things are starting to feel pretty ominous. Was Hong Kong going to become just like any other Chinese city run by the communists?
当然，没人知道到2047年中国全面接管香港时，这一切会走向何方。但对珍妮弗和许多她这个年纪的人来说，事情开始感觉非常不祥。香港会变得像任何其他由共产党管理的中国城市一样吗？
When you're 50, what do you picture life here will be like?
当你50岁的时候，你想象这里的生活会是什么样子的？
I can picture that I will be super depressed because I super like comment on political things. I really cannot imagine the day that I cannot speak freely on internet, that we do not have that freedom of speech anymore. And I cannot imagine that there will come a day me and my friends commenting on the government would become a crime.
我可以想象我会超级抑郁，因为我超级喜欢评论政治话题。我真的无法想象有一天我不能在互联网上自由发言，我们不再拥有言论自由。我无法想象有一天我和我的朋友评论政府会成为一种罪行。
And you think that would happen.
你认为那会发生。
Yes, I do, when all the things that is happening in mainland China now, especially, I would say, in-- where is it-- Xinjiang.
是的，考虑到现在在中国大陆发生的所有事情，特别是，我想，在……在哪里……新疆。
Xinjiang.
新疆。
Yeah, what is happening in Xinjiang will happen in Hong Kong.
是的，发生在新疆的事情也会发生在香港。
She's talking about internment camps where the Chinese are holding perhaps a million Uighurs and others.
她指的是拘留营，中国在那里关押了大约一百万维吾尔族人和其他人。
They say is re-education, but it's basically a concentration camp. They put people who do not agree with the government into the concentration camp and educate them. And they got monitored wherever and whenever they go. Everywhere is police. Police monitors everybody's move. And I do think that if we do not fight for our future, there will come a day Hong Kong will become like Xinjiang.
他们说是再教育，但这基本上就是集中营。他们把不同意政府的人关进集中营进行教育。他们无论走到哪里、何时走，都被监视。到处都是警察。警察监视着每个人的举动。我确实认为，如果我们不为我们的未来而战，香港终有一天会变得像新疆一样。
Because she's politically active, this does not feel like an abstract threat. When these 22-year-olds picture who China's going to crack down on, it's them.
因为她积极参与政治，这感觉不像是一个抽象的威胁。当这些22岁的年轻人设想中国会镇压谁时，那就是他们。
Tiffany's also in her first job out of college. She works at a bank. She asked us to replace her voice with an actress.
蒂芙尼大学毕业后也从事第一份工作。她在一家银行工作。她要求我们用配音演员代替她的声音。
Who knows whatever they would do to us? And under the extradition bill, who knows where we will go, what time we will disappear? That's what we fear of.
谁知道他们会对我们做什么？在引渡法下，谁知道我们会去哪里，什么时候会消失？这就是我们害怕的。
Tiffany's heard of the social credit system that China has started to monitor and rate its citizens. She fears that if China decides that you're anti-government, it will make it impossible for you to get the job you want or rise in society. And the devices the China uses to monitor its population, an estimated 200 million surveillance cameras around the country with facial recognition software, they've been going up around Hong Kong, tens of thousands of them.
蒂芙尼听说过中国开始监视和评定公民的社会信用体系。她担心如果中国认定你是反政府的，你将无法获得想要的工作或在社会中晋升。而中国用来监视人口的设备，全国估计有2亿个配备面部识别软件的监控摄像头，它们已经在香港安装了，有数万个。
Many, like me, are scared of being monitored and rated so that we will never, ever be free to do anything that we want under the monitoring of the Chinese government.
像我这样的人很多，都害怕被监视和评分，以至于我们在中国政府的监控下永远不可能自由地做任何我们想做的事情。
This is something else I didn't understand before I came to Hong Kong. The protesters like Tiffany and Jennifer don't just fear what's going to happen to them in the future, with extradition laws or losing the internet or losing free speech. In their daily lives right now, they believe they're watching China already transforming Hong Kong, making it less like the Hong Kong they know and more like the mainland.
这是我在来香港之前不了解的另一件事。像蒂芙尼和珍妮弗这样的抗议者不仅担心未来会发生什么，担心引渡法、失去互联网或失去言论自由。在她们现在的日常生活中，她们认为自己已经看到中国正在改变香港，使它变得越来越不像她们熟悉的香港，而越来越像大陆。
Jennifer points to changes in the public school curricula. Like, she says, her seven-year-old nephew is speaking Mandarin in school five days a week. That didn't happen when she was a kid. Mandarin's what they speak in mainland China. In Hong Kong, people mostly speak in Cantonese and in English.
珍妮弗指出了公立学校课程的变化。她说，她七岁的侄子每周五天在学校讲普通话。这在她小时候并没有发生。普通话是中国大陆讲的语言。在香港，人们大多讲粤语和英语。
So all the Chinese classes are conducted in Mandarin. So he speaks Mandarin everyday, basically. He speaks Mandarin better than English.
所以所有的中文课都是用普通话授课的。所以他基本上每天都讲普通话。他讲普通话比讲英语还好。
Can you explain a little bit why Cantonese is so important?
你能解释一下为什么粤语这么重要吗？
Cantonese is more like an identity to us.
粤语对我们来说更像是一种身份。
It's part of what makes Hong Kong Hong Kong. These days, when Jennifer pictures what her life is going to be like between now and 2047, she imagines her own kids going to public schools, not studying Cantonese, coming home and parroting the pro-government line that'll be the curriculum by then.
这是使香港成为香港的一部分。这些天，当珍妮弗想象她从现在到2047年的生活时，她想象自己的孩子去公立学校，不学粤语，回到家鹦鹉学舌般地念着到那时将成为课程大纲的亲政府言论。
So, I do love kids. I really want to have kids. I want to have a football team of kids, really. But I just cannot imagine the life they will be having in Hong Kong later on. I cannot promise my kid a happy life if I am not certain about what will Hong Kong become.
所以，我确实喜欢孩子。我真的很想要孩子。我想要一支足球队那么多的孩子，真的。但我只是无法想象他们在香港以后会过的生活。如果我不确定香港会变成什么样，我就无法保证我的孩子会有幸福的生活。
You don't think there are children who are raised to be happy in mainland China?
你认为中国大陆没有孩子被培养成幸福的人吗？
Not the kind of happy that I think. Mainland China people, they think that they are happy because they can still live. But we want things more than just surviving in this society. We look for rights and freedoms and human rights. But the mainland China, they ignore all those things. They just think having a stable life, having kids, having food, a good place to live in is already happy enough. Yeah.
不是我认为的那种幸福。中国大陆的人，他们认为自己很幸福，因为他们还能活着。但我们想要的东西远不止仅仅在这个社会中生存。我们寻求权利、自由和人权。但中国大陆，他们忽视了所有这些。他们只是认为拥有稳定的生活、有孩子、有食物、有一个好的地方住就已经足够幸福了。是的。
Another change she says she's seeing right now in Hong Kong, she's upset at all the mainlanders moving there in her neighborhood, and university students that she and her friends encountered at college. So many mainlanders, she says.
她说她在香港看到的另一个变化是，她对所有搬到那里住在她社区的大陆人，以及她和朋友在大学里遇到的大陆学生感到心烦。她说，大陆人太多了。
I just feel really weird because I am born and raised in Hong Kong. I go to a local school, but then I have to be surrounded by all the mainlanders.
我真的觉得很奇怪，因为我是在香港出生长大的。我上的是本地学校，但却不得不被所有大陆人包围。
Does it bother you to be surrounded by mainlanders?
被大陆人包围让你困扰吗？
Yes, actually, quite. But then we have 150 new immigrants from China to Hong Kong every day.
是的，实际上，相当困扰。但我们每天有150名来自中国的新移民到香港。
Oh, yeah, I'm just going to pause the tape there for a second. The total, by the way, is over a million mainlanders since 1997, roughly 45,000 a year. But I'm stopping the tape because I don't know how you're feeling about Jennifer, but this was a point we came to in a few interviews with these 22-year-olds. When you got them under the subject of mainlanders, get ready for a wave of totally bigoted opinions.
噢，是的，我先暂停一下录音。顺便说一下，自1997年以来，总数已经超过一百万大陆人，大约每年4.5万人。但我停止录音是因为我不知道你对珍妮弗感觉如何，但这确实是我们与这些22岁年轻人进行几次采访时提到的一个点。当你把话题引到大陆人身上时，准备好迎接一波完全偏执的言论吧。
So especially I live in New Territories. So all the people surrounding you, you hear Mandarin, and then you start to see those less educated people, they're squatting next to the streets. I did witness a mainland lady having her children pee at the road. And I always hear mainland people yelling, shouting out for nothing in the mall. And always, they jump into the line-- everything. It bothers me a lot.
所以，我特别住在新界。所以所有在你周围的人，你听到普通话，然后你开始看到那些受教育程度较低的人，他们蹲在街边。我确实目睹了一位大陆女士让她的孩子在路上小便。我总是听到大陆人在商场里没缘由地大喊大叫。而且总是，他们插队——所有事情。这让我很困扰。
Squatting, what do you mean squatting?
蹲，你指的是什么蹲？
I don't know. They just squat on the roadside, waiting people.
我不知道。他们只是蹲在路边，等人。
They just sit and squat and wait.
他们只是坐着蹲着等。
Yeah, for nothing. They can squat for an hour.
是的，没缘由。他们可以蹲上一个小时。
People in Hong Kong don't do that.
香港人不那样做。
Yeah, we don't, 'cause who would squat at the road? Why can't you can't stand? Or why you can't just sit?
是的，我们不，因为谁会蹲在路上？为什么你不能站着？或者为什么你不能坐着？
They're more comfortable.
他们觉得更舒服。
It just doesn't look good. It doesn't look good. It doesn't look civilized.
这看起来不好。看起来不文明。
So for all the alarm that Jennifer and the cursed generation feel about the future, the parents are often not as alarmed about China taking more control of Hong Kong and about what the island's going to be like in 2047. Like Tiffany's parents, they hate her going out to protest every weekend.
因此，尽管珍妮弗和被诅咒的一代对未来感到恐慌，但他们的父母通常对中国加强对香港的控制以及2047年这个岛会变成什么样并不那么恐慌。像蒂芙尼的父母，他们讨厌她每个周末出去抗议。
I think for my parents, they-- we really had some very serious fights.
我想对于我的父母，他们……我们确实发生了一些非常严重的争吵。
And they think, we'll just let China take over Hong Kong. It'll be fine.
他们认为，我们就让中国接管香港吧。会没事的。
I think my parents, some of the older generation just don't believe, or they are not brave enough to open up their eyes and see what is actually going to happen. They just feel like they did not do anything wrong. As long as you did not do anything wrong, then you'd be fine.
我想我的父母，一些老一代只是不相信，或者他们不够勇敢去睁开眼睛看看实际上会发生什么。他们只是觉得他们没有做错任何事。只要你没做错任何事，你就会没事。
What's galling about this for Tiffany is that she feels like she's being the responsible one, fighting for everybody's future. And they're telling her not to protest. She was like, maybe if your parents had done this themselves years ago, things wouldn't be so bad today.
对蒂芙尼来说，最让她恼火的是，她觉得自己在承担责任，为每个人的未来而战。而他们却告诉她不要抗议。她想，也许如果你的父母多年前自己这么做的话，今天的事情就不会这么糟糕了。
I'm 22 years old. And in the past, when I was younger, they have never stood up like us or fight like us to ask for what they are promised in 1997.
我22岁。过去，当我更年轻的时候，他们从未像我们一样挺身而出或战斗，去争取1997年承诺给他们的东西。
It's funny. When you talk about it, you're mad at your parents about it.
这很有趣。当你谈论它时，你对你的父母感到愤怒。
I just feel like-- I mean, I don't understand why they would not want these rights or why they don't think that something bad is going to happen in the next 50 years.
我只是觉得——我是说，我不明白为什么他们不想要这些权利，或者为什么他们不认为未来50年内会发生什么糟糕的事情。
So Tiffany and Jennifer and so many others, they've kind of given over their lives to protesting. They work during the week, protest on the weekends. They say they don't have much time in their lives for much else. But what's interesting is, they don't think it's going to work. Most of our interviewees told us that. They don't think China is going to give in. Again, here's Jennifer.
所以蒂芙尼和珍妮弗以及许多其他人，他们基本上把自己的生活献给了抗议。他们在工作日工作，周末抗议。他们说除了这些，他们的生活里没有太多时间做其他事。但有趣的是，他们认为这不会奏效。我们大多数受访者都这么告诉我们。他们不认为中国会屈服。再次，这是珍妮弗。
I am pretty much pessimistic, actually. I do wish that one day, we all succeed. We want a democratic Hong Kong, but now, I just don't see a way out. It's been three months. We've been trying each and every step. We've broke into the legislative council. We have more than 1,000 people got arrested. But the government is still trying to ignore all of this.
我实际上相当悲观。我确实希望有一天，我们都能成功。我们想要一个民主的香港，但现在，我只是看不到出路。已经三个月了。我们一直在尝试每一步。我们闯入了立法会。我们有超过1000人被捕。但政府仍然试图无视这一切。
If you feel so pessimistic about the results, why still go? Why are you still going out every weekend?
如果你对结果如此悲观，为什么还要去？为什么你仍然每个周末都要出去？
At least the governments see that we are not that-- how do we say-- we are not that obedient. So we have to continuously tell the government that we are not satisfied with what they are giving us. So we have to do it.
至少政府看到我们不是那么……我们该怎么说……我们不是那么顺从。所以我们必须不断地告诉政府，我们对他们给予我们的东西不满意。所以我们必须这样做。
Again, here's Alice.
再次，这是爱丽丝。
I think even if we have to lose, we need to leave our true thoughts in history. We need to let the people behind us know that we've tried.
我想即使我们必须输，我们也需要在历史中留下我们真实的思想。我们需要让身后的人知道我们尝试过。
2047 is coming, and this is a very grand thing to say, but so many of these curse generation kids feel like they have a special destiny. Alex preferred to speak to us through an interpreter. She's a frontline protester, builds barricades, has been arrested.
2047年就要来了，这是一个非常宏大的说法，但这么多这些被诅咒一代的孩子觉得他们有一种特殊的命运。亚历克斯更愿意通过翻译与我们交谈。她是一名一线抗议者，负责修筑路障，曾被捕过。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
I think we're actually lucky because we grew up with people who thought the same way. And we realized that when we turn 50, it's the end of our freedoms. I'm 22 now, and I imagine that when I'm 25, that's really halfway until the bomb explodes.
我想我们其实很幸运，因为我们和有同样想法的人一起长大。我们意识到，当我们50岁时，那是我们自由的终点。我现在22岁，我想象当我也25岁时，那离炸弹爆炸真的只有一半的路程了。
And so if we don't do anything, by the time we're 50 years old, it would be awful. I don't want our children to have the same battle. And then when we're 50, we'll look back and think that we didn't do enough. Our birthday is like a countdown to the end. And so, more so than other people, I feel like my generation, we have a duty to do more.
所以如果我们什么都不做，等到我们50岁时，那将是可怕的。我不希望我们的孩子有同样的战斗。然后当我们50岁时，我们会回头看，认为我们做得不够。我们的生日就像是终点的倒计时。所以，比其他人更甚，我觉得我这一代，我们有责任做更多。
Again, here's Jennifer.
再次，这是珍妮弗。
If we were born earlier, probably I would become my dad and mom. And if I were born later, I would probably become those little kids speaking Mandarin better than Cantonese. So I am happy that I am born in 1997. We are in the middle. We have the chance to know what is freedom, and we are experiencing that our freedom is being taken away. And that's why we are the group who step up first to fight for it.
如果我们出生得更早，我可能会变成我的父亲和母亲。如果我们出生得更晚，我可能会变成那些讲普通话比讲粤语更好的小孩子。所以我很高兴我出生在1997年。我们处于中间。我们有机会知道什么是自由，我们正在经历我们的自由被夺走。这就是为什么我们是第一批挺身而出争取自由的群体。
I think we're getting off here. I think we are getting off.
我想我们要在这里下车了。我想我们要下车了。
After an hour bus ride, we get to the protest. This is Act Two, The Fight. Once you're off of the bus, Jennifer ducks into a public restroom and comes out in black shirt, black pants, black mask over her face, hair pulled back in a ponytail. And we head on to a street where we're surrounded by hundreds of people dressed exactly like her.
在经历了一小时的巴士车程后，我们到达了抗议现场。这是第二幕：战斗。一旦下车，珍妮弗躲进了一个公共厕所，出来时戴着黑衬衫、黑裤子，脸上戴着黑口罩，头发扎成马尾辫。我们前往一条街道，周围被数百名衣着和她完全一样的人包围着。
A big shopping district, the stores closed, and no cars. All the side streets have been blocked off with barricades by the protesters-- scaffolding and fencing, trashcans, and orange construction cones piled in the street. They do an efficient job. We meet up with Jennifer's friends by a big Victoria's Secret store.
一个大型购物区，商店关门了，没有汽车。所有的小街道都被抗议者用路障封锁了——脚手架和栅栏、垃圾桶和堆在街上的橙色建筑锥体。他们工作很高效。我们在一家大型维多利亚的秘密店旁和珍妮弗的朋友们会合了。
My friend.
我的朋友。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Nice to meet you, Ira.
很高兴见到你，艾拉。
Nice to meet you, man. Yes.
很高兴见到你，伙计。是的。
Very nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
The couple who always kiss in front of me.
总是在我面前亲吻的那对情侣。
What? I'm not.
什么？我没有。
No, we didn't. We didn't.
不，我们没有。我们没有。
For the record, I'm with them all afternoon-- no kissing at all. The city is giving permission for fewer protests these days, and this is an unsanctioned demonstration we're at, which means that everybody here is breaking the law. Anyone is subject to arrest, which affects crowd size. The maximum penalty is five years-- 10 years, if you're convicted of rioting-- which is why all the protesters are so scared of getting arrested all the time.
郑重声明，我和他们在一起整个下午——根本没有亲吻。如今，政府批准的抗议活动减少了，我们所在的这是一场未经批准的示威，这意味着在场的每个人都在违法。任何人都有可能被逮捕，这影响了人群的规模。最高刑罚是五年——如果你被判暴动罪则是10年——这就是为什么所有的抗议者一直都如此害怕被捕。
But despite that, the beginning of the protest has the feeling of a block party. People strolling, chatting-- you see a few parents and kids. Some non-protesters cut through the crowd, running errands. But an hour into all this, I look around and realize-- no families, no kids. It's not feeling like a block party at all. People are standing on top of fences, trying to see what's ahead of us. They're starting to put on gas masks.
但尽管如此，抗议的开始有一种街区派对的感觉。人们漫步、聊天——你会看到一些家长和孩子。一些非抗议者跑腿时穿过人群。但一个小时后，我环顾四周意识到——没有家庭，没有孩子。这根本不像街区派对。人们站在栅栏上，试图看清前面有什么。他们开始戴上防毒面具。
Describe what you're seeing.
描述一下你所看到的。
The protesters in the Thomas Street are moving backwards, so we assume that there are riot police on the other end of the road. There is tear gas fired over there.
托马斯街的抗议者正在向后移动，所以我们推测道路的另一端有防暴警察。那边发射了催泪瓦斯。
It's like two or three blocks away. We walk towards the police and the tear gas, past teams of protesters who are knocking bricks out of the sidewalk with long steel tools.
那大概在两三个街区之外。我们走向警察和催泪瓦斯，路过一组组用长钢工具敲掉人行道砖块的抗议者。
And the idea is what?
想法是什么？
To put on the road so, later on, the riot police cannot run that fast.
把它放在路上，这样以后防暴警察就跑不快了。
Also, people throw bricks at the police. We march straight to the frontlines, where hundreds of protesters are massed on a side street. The police are just half a block away, but we can't really see them through the crowd. And then a whole wave of tear gas canisters arcs towards us, hits us.
此外，人们向警察扔砖头。我们径直走向前线，那里数百名抗议者聚集在一条小巷里。警察就在半个街区之外，但我们透过人群无法真正看到他们。然后一整波催泪瓦斯弹向我们袭来，击中了我们。
And lots of people, us included, run back a ways, half a block away. Jennifer calmly administers saline solution into strangers' eyes. The controls on my recorder got knocked around running through the smoke, so I do not have a decent recording of that.
很多人，包括我们在内，向后跑了一段距离，退出了半个街区。珍妮弗冷静地向陌生人的眼睛里滴入生理盐水。由于在烟雾中奔跑，我录音机的控制键被撞乱了，所以我没有那段清晰的录音。
This is the role that she's assigned herself in the protest-- first aid, helping anybody who requires it. She even brought energy candy specifically to give out to people whose energy is flagging. After being driven back, Jennifer and her two friends and I wait for the smoke to clear.
这就是她在抗议中为自己分配的角色——急救，帮助任何有需要的人。她甚至带了能量糖果，专门分发给那些精力不足的人。被击退后，珍妮弗和她的两个朋友以及我等待烟雾散去。
So this happens at every protest?
每次抗议都会发生这种情况吗？
Yes.
是的。
Basically.
基本是。
So what do we do now?
那我们现在做什么？
We tidy up ourselves and go again.
我们整理好自己，再次出发。
And when you get to the police, what are you going to do?
当你到达警察那里时，你会做什么？
We're going to stand in front of them. If we have a chance, we're going to fight them back. Our goal is to make them to retreat their front line.
我们将站在他们面前。如果有机会，我们会反击。我们的目标是让他们撤退前线。
After a couple minutes, we head back toward the front line.
几分钟后，我们再次回到前线。
OK, we're walking forward to its corner, where it's this blue-- [COUGHS]
好的，我们正向前走向角落，那里是那种蓝色……（咳嗽）
And then we wait around. A water cannon goes off, blasting water that is dyed blue, laced with stuff that stings your skin. More tear gas, and we pull back a little. Then we move forward, wait again.
然后我们就在附近等待。水炮车启动了，喷射出染成蓝色的水，里面掺杂着刺痛皮肤的东西。更多催泪瓦斯，我们向后撤了一点。然后我们向前移动，再次等待。
This is both suspenseful and boring.
这既悬疑又无聊。
[LAUGHS] Sometimes there's not always a purpose. Sometimes we sitting at the back is just as a support. We just act as a support to those at the front.
（笑）有时并不总是有一个目的。有时我们坐在后面只是作为一种支持。我们只是对那些在前线的人给予支持。
Support like, if something happens, you'll do first aid?
支持比如，如果发生什么事，你会做急救？
Something like this, but also they know that there are many people behind them. It is important to give them some mental support as well. Yeah.
类似这样，但他们也知道后面有很多人。给他们一些精神上的支持也很重要。是的。
So many protesters are like Jennifer. They feel like it's their job to support the people at the front, who are the hardcore ones, who push back against police and throw Molotov cocktails, and chase police with sticks and metal rods, and tear stuff down to build barriers to slow the police, wearing full gear, helmets and goggles and gas masks and gloves.
很多抗议者都像珍妮弗。他们觉得自己的工作是支持前线的人，那些是强硬派，他们反抗警察，投掷汽油弹，用棍棒和金属棒追打警察，拆掉东西建造路障来阻碍警察，全副武装，戴着头盔、护目镜、防毒面具和手套。
Finally, the frontliners yell that they want room to retreat. And so we need to retreat. And so we fall way back, a couple blocks.
最后，前线人员大喊他们需要撤退的空间。所以我们需要撤退。我们向后撤了很远，几个街区。
So now we're just standing here.
所以现在我们只是站在这里。
Yeah, because we always support. Our assistance is like a support to those in the front line.
是的，因为我们总是支持。我们的协助就像是对前线人员的支持。
But I don't understand. So the police want us out of there. They push, they fire tear gas. They spray blue water on everybody. We move back. And then we stand here, and what's our goal?
但我还是不明白。警察想让我们离开那里。他们推进，他们发射催泪瓦斯。他们对所有人喷射蓝水。我们向后移动。然后我们站在这里，我们的目标是什么？
This has been a very frequently asked question. Nowadays, we're just trying to stand on our own ground, not to be dispersed that easily.
这是一个非常常见的问题。如今，我们只是试图守住阵地，不那么容易被驱散。
That's it. Just, the goal is to just stay out as long as you can.
就是这样。目标只是尽可能久地待在外面。
Yeah.
是的。
And then eventually, the police will push you off the street? So in other words, it's exactly like the entire protest movement leading to 2047. Just try to slow them down as much as you can.
然后最终，警察会把你从街上推开？换句话说，这完全就像通向2047年的整个抗议运动。只是试着尽可能地拖慢他们。
Yes.
是的。
In the end, China will win. But for as long as you can, you'll just stand here in the street.
最后，中国会赢。但只要可能，你就只是站在这里的街上。
It is pretty sad to say so, but I guess that's pretty much accurate. Yeah.
说这话很悲哀，但我猜这相当准确。是的。
What are they yelling?
他们在喊什么？
They ask people to start moving.
他们要求人们开始行动。
And then we headed to a massive retreat, as the police advance towards us. And for the first time, there seems to be actual real fear. We're running down the streets and side roads. We get separated from Jennifer's friends and from Emanuele, dodging the police, and finally, taking refuge in a church. There are safe houses like this around Hong Kong that protesters duck into. It takes over an hour, and finally, the coast is clear.
然后我们开始了一场大规模的撤退，因为警察向我们推进。这是第一次，似乎有了真正的恐惧。我们在街道和小路上奔跑。我们和珍妮弗的朋友以及埃曼纽尔失散了，躲避警察，最后在教堂避难。香港各处都有这样的安全屋，抗议者会钻进去。花了一个多小时，海岸终于清静了。
And Jennifer calls her friend to pick her up. They're volunteer drivers for the protesters, part of the infrastructure they've created. Jennifer changes out of her black T-shirt into civilian clothes. No makeup-- she's too tired, she says, and no need, if she's getting picked up.
珍妮弗叫了她的朋友来接她。他们是抗议者的志愿者司机，是他们建立的基础设施的一部分。珍妮弗脱下黑色T恤，换上了平民装束。没化妆——她说她太累了，而且如果有人接她，也没必要化妆。
Bye.
再见。
And she heads home.
然后她回家了。
Say goodbye to Emanuele for me as well. Thank you.
也替我跟埃曼纽尔说再见。谢谢。
As her car pulled away, across the street on Queens Road, there was an endless row of police vehicles headed in the other direction, just dozens of them, blue and red lights flashing. And as night went on, things became violent. A woman approached us on the sidewalk, upset about police beating somebody, and showed us video that she'd shot of it.
当她的车开走时，在皇后大道对面，有一长排警察车辆正朝另一个方向驶去，足足有几十辆，蓝红灯闪烁。随着夜幕降临，事情变得暴力了。一名女子在人行道上走近我们，对警察殴打某人感到不安，并向我们展示了她拍摄的视频。
And the protesters were violent as well. The newspapers had accounts of six of them beating up a middle-aged man, kicking and shouting at him. They set fire to a subway station. They do that a lot because lots of protesters think Hong Kong subway-- the MTR-- colludes with the police. That's why Jennifer prefers the bus, even though it's less convenient.
抗议者也很暴力。报纸上有他们六个人殴打一名中年男子，踢打并对他大喊大叫的报道。他们放火烧了一个地铁站。他们经常这样做，因为很多抗议者认为香港地铁——MTR——与警察勾结。这就是为什么珍妮弗更喜欢坐巴士，尽管没那么方便。
Every protester we interviewed supports the violence. They support it because they feel like they have no other options, that it's the only way they can get the government to respond to them. A few told us, back in June, they marched peacefully against the extradition bill and got nothing. Then they got violent, and the bill was withdrawn. It worked.
我们采访的每一位抗议者都支持暴力。他们支持它是因为他们觉得别无选择，这是他们能让政府回应他们的唯一途径。几个人在六月份告诉我们，他们和平游行反对引渡法，结果什么也没得到。然后他们变得暴力，该法案就被撤回了。这奏效了。
And violence has become a way to defend themselves. Setting fires and building barricades slows police, who were coming after them. So they support the violence, or they at least understand it. Emanuele talked to them about that. We're at Act Three of our show, On Civil Disobedience. Here's Emanuele.
而且暴力已经成为保护自己的一种方式。放火和建造路障阻碍了追踪他们的警察。所以他们支持暴力，或者至少他们理解它。埃曼纽尔和他们谈论了这一点。我们现在进入节目的第三幕，关于公民不服从。这是埃曼纽尔。
When I started asking protesters about violence, a couple of them said, we're not violent like Americans. Our tolerance for it is much lower. So getting to this point to being OK with violence isn't something we did lightly. And a lot of them explained to me that they didn't always think radical tactics were OK.
当我开始询问抗议者关于暴力的问题时，有几个人说，我们不像美国人那样暴力。我们对暴力的容忍度低得多。所以走到这一步，对暴力感到接受，并不是我们轻率做出的决定。他们中的很多人向我解释，他们并不总是认为激进的策略是没问题的。
What changed their opinion was the way police responded to peaceful protest. That being shot at with water cannons, tear gassed, seeing someone knocked unconscious, beaten with batons, handcuffed and kicked, groups of thugs beating and attacking people with hammers, clubs, and knives, watching all this and being subjected to it-- that's what got a lot of people on board with violence. Now some protesters throw Molotov cocktails, vandalize buildings, and chase police with sticks and rods. Ira and I talked with one protester, Yuen.
改变他们观点的是警察对和平抗议的回应。被水炮射击、催泪瓦斯喷射，看着有人被打得失去知觉，用警棍殴打，戴上手铐被踢打，成群的暴徒用锤子、棍棒和刀具攻击人们，目睹这一切并亲身经历——这就是让很多人支持暴力的原因。现在一些抗议者投掷汽油弹，破坏建筑物，用棍棒和铁棒追打警察。艾拉和我也和一位抗议者媛交谈过。
Do you think it would be acceptable for the protesters to kill police?
你认为抗议者杀警察可以接受吗？
I hope they do so.
我希望他们这样做。
You do?
你真的这样认为吗？
I do.
我确实这样认为。
If police died, what do you think would happen next?
如果警察死了，你认为接下来会发生什么？
We would die, too. Protesters will die, too.
我们也会死。抗议者也会死。
And if things get that violent between the protesters and the police and protesters are being killed, do you think Hong Kong will get democracy?
如果抗议者和警察之间变得如此暴力，抗议者被杀，你认为香港能实现民主吗？
I can't tell at the moment.
我目前无法判断。
So many people we talked with expected someone to die-- a protester or a police officer. Most thought it would help the movement put pressure on the government. This hasn't happened yet, but destruction and violence are giving way to bizarre scenes throughout the city. My co-worker Diane and I went to this protest at a mall, one of many in Hong Kong.
我们交谈过的很多人都预料到会有人死亡——一名抗议者或一名警察。大多数人认为这将有助于运动给政府施加压力。这还没有发生，但破坏和暴力正在导致整个城市出现怪异的场景。我的同事戴安和我去了一个商场抗议，这是香港众多的商场之一。
Sometimes the entire city can feel like one giant Chinese shopping mall connected by subway. The stores are all open. The mall is full of people. But not many people are shopping. The entire premise of this protest is to go to the mall and not shop.
有时整个城市感觉就像一个巨大的中国购物中心，由地铁连接。商店都开着。商场里挤满了人。但没多少人在购物。这场抗议的前提就是去商场但不购物。
The mall is five stories. Each tier has railings that look out over a central atrium. There are families, kids, older folks. Some people are in black. Others are just in their regular day clothes. They chant. They sing the protester anthem, "Glory to Hong Kong," over and over.
商场有五层楼高。每一层都有俯瞰中央中庭的护栏。有家庭、孩子、老年人。有些人穿着黑色衣服。其他人只是穿着普通的日常服装。他们喊口号。他们一遍又一遍地唱抗议者的赞歌《愿荣光归香港》。
[PROTESTERS SINGING]
（抗议者歌唱）
At one point, someone starts handing out paper, and suddenly hundreds of people are folding paper cranes. Then, an act of gentle vandalism. There's this machine that prints out reservation receipts for the restaurant called Jade Garden. The protesters hijack it, forcing it to spit out hundreds of receipts. They tape the receipts together and string them from one end of the atrium to the other and back again a few times.
突然，有人开始分发纸张，刹那间数百人在折纸鹤。然后，一种温和的破坏行为发生了。有一台机器会为一家名为“翡翠花园”的餐馆打印预约收据。抗议者劫持了它，强迫它吐出数百张收据。他们把收据粘在一起，从中庭的一端拉到另一端，又来回几次。
They target Jade Garden because one of the company's founders has a daughter who supports Beijing. That's how far things have gone in Hong Kong. Businesses are labeled either yellow or blue-- yellow for the ones that support the protesters, blue for the police and government. There's even a Google Map that tells you if a business is one or the other.
他们针对“翡翠花园”是因为该公司的一位创始人有一个支持北京的女儿。香港的事情已经发展到这个地步了。企业被贴上黄色或蓝色的标签——黄色代表那些支持抗议者的，蓝色代表支持警察和政府的。甚至有一个谷歌地图会告诉你企业是哪一类的。
Soon, things in the mall start to shift. Diane and I watch a group of about a dozen protesters enter a pro-China bakery, owned by the same company that owns Jade Garden. They start taunting the staff.
很快，商场里的气氛开始转变。戴安和我看着大约一打抗议者进入一家亲中的面包店，那家店由拥有“翡翠花园”的同一家公司所有。他们开始嘲弄员工。
There's umbrellas up.
雨伞举起来了。
They're blocking so you can't really see inside of it.
他们挡着，你真的看不见里面。
Is the person who works in there still in there?
里面工作的人还在里面吗？
Yeah-- well, she was a minute ago.
是的——嗯，一分钟前还在。
OK, something fell.
好的，什么东西掉了。
They knocked over a display.
他们打翻了一个展示柜。
Before things can escalate any further, the workers force the protesters out, close the store gates, and barricade themselves in. A restless energy takes over. It's like the protesters are looking for something to confront, something to disturb. But the thing they're fighting against is the existential threat of China. And that's not really in the mall.
在事情进一步升级之前，工人们把抗议者强行赶出去，关上了商店大门，把自己封锁在里面。一种躁动的能量占据了上风。好像抗议者在寻找什么东西来对抗，寻找什么东西来扰乱。但他们斗争的对象是中国的生存威胁。这在商场里真的不存在。
They march to more pro-China businesses in the mall. The alarm starts going off, and a PA announcement says, "The mall is very crowded. Please be careful." Then word comes police are on their way, and some mood that feels like a mix of fear and adrenaline fills the space.
他们前往商场里更多的亲中企业。警报开始响起，广播公告说：“商场非常拥挤。请小心。”然后有消息说警察正在赶来，一种混合了恐惧和肾上腺素的感觉填满了空间。
Protesters begin to build barriers out of whatever is not nailed to the ground, blocking doorways, creating obstacles. They want to stop the police from entering from the subway entrance of the mall. They start throwing trash cans down the escalators. A group rips a six-foot TV screen out of a wall to use as part of a blockade.
抗议者开始用地上未固定的任何东西建造路障，封锁门口，制造障碍。他们想阻止警察从商场的地铁入口进入。他们开始把垃圾桶扔下扶梯。一群人从墙上撕下一个六英尺的电视屏幕用作路障的一部分。
The PA announcement remains the same. "Please be careful. The mall is very crowded." They open an emergency firehose. Someone brings giant jugs of oil, which they add to the water. The tile floor of the mall lobby is now a little lake that police will have to cross. A woman slips and falls.
广播公告保持不变。“请小心。商场非常拥挤。”他们打开了紧急消防水管。有人带了巨大的油罐，倒进水里。商场大厅的瓷砖地面现在是一个警察必须穿过的小湖。一名妇女滑倒了。
And while all this destruction is happening, the shoppers, the older folks, even a few families, they don't leave. They're on the upper levels of the mall, looking over the railing, like they're watching a sporting event or something. I'm super uncomfortable. The protester next to us, Chan, is so chill.
当这一切破坏正在发生时，购物者、老年人，甚至几个家庭，他们都没有离开。他们在商场的高层，看着护栏，就像在看体育比赛之类的。我感到非常不舒服。旁边的抗议者陈非常冷静。
Have you been to a protest like this before?
你以前参加过这样的抗议吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Does this feel normal?
这感觉正常吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Is that weird that it's normal, though?
这很正常，不觉得奇怪吗？
Yes, but it's been 100 days, so.
是的，但已经100天了，所以。
The police eventually come, but they meet the protesters outside the mall. They throw tear gas. Protesters threw a Molotov cocktail. Smoke and gas waft through Snoopy World, a mini theme park on one of the mall's upper levels. Giant statues of Linus and Peppermint Patty, along with dozens of shoppers and protesters, who lined the outdoor balconies, all watch the confrontation between police and protesters unfold below.
警察最终赶到了，但他们在商场外遇到了抗议者。他们投掷催泪瓦斯。抗议者投掷了一枚汽油弹。烟雾和气体飘过了史努比世界，这是商场高层的一个小型主题公园。林纳斯和薄荷帕蒂的巨大雕像，以及数十名沿着户外阳台排队的购物者和抗议者，都目睹了下面警察和抗议者之间的对峙。
There's this thing that protesters say to each other-- never sever ties. Sometimes they even say, never sever ties even if there's a nuclear explosion. Basically, if another protester does something you disagree with-- say, set something on fire, beat someone up-- you don't criticize them or cut them off.
抗议者之间有一句口号——不割席。有时他们甚至说，即使发生核爆炸也不割席。基本上，如果另一个抗议者做了你不同意的事情——比如点燃了什么东西，殴打某人——你不会批评他们或断绝关系。
My co-worker Diane saw an extreme example of this at a protest about a week later. It was a very peaceful protest in a park at night. So serene, Diane said she felt she could only whisper. Then a guy starts waving a big Chinese flag around. Protesters start shouting at him. He rips a poster out of one girl's hands. That's when the mob rushes in.
我的同事戴安大约一周后在一次抗议中看到了一个极端的例子。那是一个夜晚公园里的非常和平的抗议。那么宁静，戴安说她觉得自己只能低声说话。然后一个人开始挥舞一面大中国国旗。抗议者开始冲他大喊。他从一个女孩手中夺走了一张海报。就在那时，暴徒冲了上去。
Oh, shoot. There's someone who's on the ground. And then their head's getting smashed, and they're kicking them.
哦，糟糕。有人倒在地上。然后他们的头被砸了，他们正在踢他们。
Dozens of people walk by. And if anyone has a problem with this, they don't show it. He's left face down on the ground, bleeding from his head. Eventually, someone gets a first aid person to help.
数十人走过。如果有人对此有意见，他们也没表现出来。他被留在地上脸朝下，头部流血。最终，有人找来急救人员帮忙。
Emanuele Berry is one of the producers of our show. She used to live next door to Hong Kong in Macau for about a year. Coming up, you're a protester. You think the police are utterly immoral and indefensible. So, what do you do about the cop who happens to be your dad? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
埃曼纽尔·贝里是我们节目的制片人之一。她曾在香港隔壁的澳门住过一年左右。接下来，你是一名抗议者。你认为警察完全是不道德和不可辩护的。那么，你对碰巧是你父亲的警察做什么？请在芝加哥公共电台的节目继续之后收听。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Umbrellas Up, stories from Hong Kong and what it's like for people to live through over 100 days of protests there. I traveled to Hong Kong with my co-workers, Diane Wu and Emanuele Berry. We have arrived at Act Four of our show. Act Four, Good Cop, Bad Cop.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，雨伞撑起，来自香港的故事，以及人们在那里经历超过100天抗议活动的生活状况。我和我的同事戴安·吴、埃曼纽尔·贝里前往香港。我们已经到达节目的第四幕。第四幕：好警察，坏警察。
So as an American visiting Hong Kong for the first time, one of the things that kind of killed me was hearing that before the last few years of protests, people were really into the police. They were trusted. They were respected. And it was only the last few years, especially the last few months of protests, that changed all that. At a rally, I actually saw people chanting at a row of cops that they hoped that they and their families would die.
作为一个第一次访问香港的美国人，让我深受触动的一件事是听说在过去几年的抗议之前，人们真的很喜欢警察。他们是受信任的，受尊敬的。直到过去几年，特别是最近几个月的抗议，才改变了这一切。在一次集会上，我甚至看到人们对着一排警察高呼，希望他们和他们的家人死去。
And feelings about who to side with, the police or the protesters, they've gotten so intense, it's tearing families apart. On the Telegram app, there's a whole channel for protesters who get kicked out by their parents and need a place to live.
对于该站在哪一边——警察还是抗议者——的感受变得如此强烈，以至于它正在撕裂家庭。在Telegram应用上，有一个专门为被父母赶出家门需要地方住的抗议者开设的频道。
Alan Yu grew up in Hong Kong. He knows a family that is very far apart on this. The son is a protester. The dad is a retired police officer. And Alan had them sit down and do what nobody in Hong Kong is doing-- talk to each other. There is really no dialogue between police and protesters anywhere in Hong Kong as far as we could tell. Here's Alan.
尤阿兰在香港长大。他认识一个在这一点上分歧很大的家庭。儿子是抗议者。父亲是退休警官。尤阿兰让他们坐下来做了一件香港没人在做的事——交谈。据我们所知，香港任何地方的警察和抗议者之间都没有真正的对话。这是尤阿兰。
I've known this family since I was six. I knew them because of my friend, Jonathan. I rode the school bus with him every day. His father, Peter, was the first policeman I knew in real life. I was excited to talk to him because you never hear what the police think about the protests. Police here are not really allowed to talk to the press.
我从六岁起就认识这个家庭。我认识他们是因为我的朋友乔纳森。我和他每天一起坐校车。他的父亲彼得是我在现实生活中认识的第一位警察。我很兴奋能和他交谈，因为你从来听不到警察对这些抗议活动的看法。这里的警察其实不允许接受媒体采访。
Peter's retired, but still very connected to the force. So before the family all sat down together, I asked Peter to get together with me and my producer, Emanuele. I hadn't seen him since I was 12. Back then, people called me "Yu-don," which means fish ball, because the Cantonese for fish sounds like my surname, Yu, and because I was fat.
彼得退休了，但与警队仍有联系。所以在这个家庭坐下来之前，我请彼得和我和我的制片人埃曼纽尔聚一聚。我从12岁起就没见过他。那时，人们叫我“鱼旦”，意思是鱼蛋，因为粤语中鱼的发音听起来像我的姓氏余，也因为我当时很胖。
I won't recognize you on the street. I won't. I won't.
我在街上认不出你了。我不行。我不行。
Oh, yeah? Oh, OK.
噢，是吗？噢，好的。
Serious. I'm serious.
认真的。我是认真的。
OK. All right, I guess it's a compliment. Thank you.
好的。好吧，我猜这算是个恭维。谢谢。
He used to be very cute.
他以前很可爱。
Yeah, how?
是的，怎么说？
He used to be very fat.
他以前很胖。
As a kid, I liked Peter. He'd take time off work to stop by during recess and buy us chips and other snacks. My friend Jonathan would have his birthday parties at the police station, which we loved-- big barbecues, other policemen around. Peter was the cool dad.
小时候，我喜欢彼得。他会从工作中抽出时间在课间休息时顺道过来给我们买薯条和其他零食。我的朋友乔纳森会在警察局举行生日派对，这让我们很喜欢——大的烧烤，其他警察也在场。彼得是那个酷爸爸。
People in Hong Kong trusted, even revered, the police back then. One of the most popular TV shows was a cop show, [CHINESE], where the police were heroes. Peter's hair is gray now. He's tall, athletic. He plays tennis.
当时的香港人信任，甚至崇敬警察。最受欢迎的电视节目之一是警匪剧《陀枪师姐》，警察是英雄。彼得现在的头发是灰色的。他个子高，身材健壮。他打网球。
My nickname in tennis-- I don't know why. My nickname in tennis is Federer. Yeah.
我在网球界的绰号——我不知道为什么。我在网球界的绰号是费德勒。是的。
Federer.
费德勒。
Oh, are you good?
噢，你打得好吗？
Federer Roger. I don't know why. Maybe my skill. I don't know. I don't know why. [CHUCKLES]
费德勒罗杰。我不知道为什么。也许是因为我的技术。我不知道。我不知道为什么。（轻笑）
He still likes his dad jokes. I cannot imagine Peter ever doing what I've been seeing in these videos-- beating up unarmed protesters, kicking people on the ground. I thought surely he would object to some of those things and that his views would be complicated.
他仍然喜欢讲老掉牙的冷笑话。我无法想象彼得会做出我在视频中看到的那些事情——殴打手无寸铁的抗议者，踢地上的人。我原以为他肯定会反对其中一些事情，并且他的观点会很复杂。
From what you've seen in recent months, has there been anything that the police have done that you think you would disagree with?
从你最近几个月看到的情况来看，有什么警察做过的事情是你认为你会不同意的吗？
Nothing is perfect. But as a whole, in general, I think the police are doing a pretty good job. If it is in other police force in other countries, just look at the casualties. Just look at the column of fatal numbers. It won't be zero.
没有什么是完美的。但作为一个整体，通常来说，我认为警察做得很好。如果是其他国家的其他警察部队，看看伤亡人数。看看致命人数的列数。那不会是零。
I ask him about different situations the police have been criticized for. I even show him videos of police brutally arresting people, things I think are clearly wrong. But he always seems to have a justification for the way police behave. He says you are judging the police based on what you see in these clips. That's not fair. You don't know what the officer was facing.
我问他关于警察受到批评的各种情况。我甚至给他看警察残酷逮捕人的视频，我认为显然是错误的事情。但他似乎总是能为警察的行为辩护。他说你是在根据你在这些片段中看到的内容来评判警察。那不公平。你不知道那名警官当时面临什么。
The social media only show the part of police hitting people. But one minute ago, they've been attacked by lots of people. So one minute later, he react to the mob attacking them. So what you can see is one minute after, but you did not see the full picture.
社交媒体只显示警察打人的那部分。但在那一分钟前，他们遭到了很多人的攻击。所以在那一分钟后，他对攻击他们的暴徒做出了反应。所以你看到的只是那一分钟后，但你没有看到全貌。
He's not conflicted about police, and he isn't very sympathetic to protesters. He thinks the protests are destroying Hong Kong. The extradition bill is OK. He doesn't think China will end free speech in Hong Kong, and protesters' fear of China is way overblown and naive.
他并不因为警察感到矛盾，而且他对抗议者也没什么同情心。他认为抗议活动正在摧毁香港。引渡法是可以的。他不认为中国会终结香港的言论自由，抗议者对中国的恐惧是夸大其词且天真的。
Hong Kong being part of China. Come on. Wake up, people. Wake up. This is the fact. Whether China is good or bad, Hong Kong is part of China. If you don't like it, those people waving the United States flag, waving the Union Jack flag, if England takes you, you can go to England, yeah. You can go to Florida. Go to California. Yeah. Go. Go. If Trump takes you, yeah, go.
香港是中国的一部分。来吧。醒醒，人们。醒醒。这是事实。无论中国是好是坏，香港是中国的一部分。如果你不喜欢它，那些挥舞美国国旗、挥舞联合杰克国旗的人，如果英国收了你，你可以去英国，是的。你可以去佛罗里达。去加利福尼亚。是的。去。去。如果特朗普收了你，是的，去吧。
I'd already been worried how this family conversation was going to go. Hearing what Peter believed did not help. Peter told me he understands that Jonathan goes to protests, but doesn't ask him about it because he doesn't want any details. Jonathan said he does not ask his dad what he thinks of the way police beat and tear gas protesters for the same reason.
我已经很担心这次家庭谈话会如何进行。听到彼得所相信的事情并没有帮助。彼得告诉我他理解乔纳森去参加抗议，但没有问他细节，因为他不想知道。乔纳森说他没有问他父亲对警察殴打和用催泪瓦斯对付抗议者怎么看，原因也是一样。
It's just like if he says something-- if he says something that completely doesn't make sense to me, it sort of brings him down as a person. It's just like, I would feel like he's just, yeah, not who I thought he was, yeah.
这就像如果他说了一些事情——如果他说了一些我完全无法理解的事情，这在某种程度上让他作为一个人的形象降下来了。这就像，我会觉得他只是，是的，不是我以为的那种人，是的。
And it scares you to--
这让你感到害怕去……
Yeah.
是的。
--think that could be true.
——认为那可能是真的。
So this family does not talk about the protests at all. Tennis, yes. Soccer, yes. Pets, great. But no politics-- till tonight. They've agreed to have the conversation they've been avoiding after dinner. Jonathan's mom, Alva, washes the dishes.
所以这个家庭完全不谈论抗议活动。网球，谈；足球，谈；宠物，很好。但没有政治——直到今晚。他们同意在晚餐后进行他们一直避免的谈话。乔纳森的妈妈，阿尔瓦，在洗碗。
[ALVA HUMMING]
（阿尔瓦在哼唱）
I recognize the song right away. I'm surprised she's humming it in front of Peter. It's the protesters' new anthem, "Glory to Hong Kong." Alva is on Jonathan's side. She works with lawyers, including some in the pro-democracy camp.
我立刻认出了那首歌。我很惊讶她在彼得面前哼唱它。那是抗议者的新赞歌《愿荣光归香港》。阿尔瓦站在乔纳森那边。她与律师们一起工作，包括一些民主派阵营的律师。
I ask if Peter knows what that song is. She says, maybe. That's kind of how it's been going between her and her husband. No real discussion, but the occasional passive aggressive comment while they're watching the news, or some passive aggressive humming during dishes. This is another reason Jonathan avoids bringing up the protests. He doesn't want to start a fight between his parents.
我问彼得是否知道那是什么歌。她说，也许吧。这就是她和丈夫之间一直进行的方式。没有真正的讨论，但在看新闻时偶尔会有被动攻击性的评论，或者洗碗时哼一些被动攻击性的歌。这是乔纳森避免谈论抗议的另一个原因。他不想在父母之间挑起战争。
What would the worst scenario be like?
最坏的情况会是什么样？
Someone moving out, I guess. Yeah, because they can't stand it anymore. Yeah, I guess living apart would be the worst case scenario, I believe. Because that sort of officially means that you're no longer together, sort of, yeah.
有人搬出去，我想。是的，因为他们再也受不了了。是的，我想分居将是最坏的情况，我相信。因为那在某种程度上正式意味着你们不再在一起了，某种程度上，是的。
That could be his mom, or his dad, or him.
那可能是他的妈妈，或他的爸爸，或他自己。
We all sit at the dinner table. I don't know why they agreed to talk about this. Maybe just because I've known them for so long, and I asked. Or I hope maybe part of them wanted to talk, and I was just a good excuse. Peter's facing me, and Jonathan and Alva are next to me. Jonathan has their dog, Loki, named after the Marvel character, on his lap.
我们都坐在餐桌旁。我不知道他们为什么同意谈论这个。也许只是因为我认识他们太久了，而且我问了。或者我希望也许他们的一部分人想谈，而我只是一个很好的借口。彼得面对着我，乔纳森和阿尔瓦坐在我旁边。乔纳森腿上放着他们的狗洛基，以漫威角色命名。
The conversation starts with all of them saying, in different ways, it's fine that we don't talk about this. We all have mutual respect. Instead of talking to each other or looking at each other, they're talking to me or looking at the dog. It feels all very careful, proper, and calm. This continues for half an hour. Then, everything changes when Peter uses the word "compromise."
谈话以他们所有人用不同方式说，不谈论这个没关系而开始。我们都有相互尊重。而不是互相交谈或看着对方，他们在对我说话或看着狗。感觉一切都非常谨慎、得体且冷静。这持续了半小时。然后，当彼得用“妥协”这个词时，一切都变了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Compromise-- it's basically the government line. That's what Hong Kong's chief executive Carrie Lam says, that the protesters should stop protesting. And after that, the two sides can talk. Alva and Jonathan hear that as meaning the protesters should back down. They both lay into Peter.
妥协——这基本上是政府的路线。这就是香港特首林郑月娥所说的，抗议者应该停止抗议。此后，双方可以交谈。阿尔瓦和乔纳森听到这意思就是抗议者应该退缩。他们俩都猛烈抨击彼得。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Alva says the police are the ones who need to change. They have to calm the situation. Peter says the police are doing their job. I don't know why, when the police arrest people for fighting or breaking stuff, it's treated as weird. It's illegal, so arrest them. No problem.
阿尔瓦说警察才是需要改变的一方。他们必须平息局势。彼得说警察在做他们的工作。我不知道为什么，当警察逮捕因打架或破坏东西的人时，它被视为奇怪的事情。这是非法的，所以逮捕他们。没问题。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Jonathan says, OK, yes, arrest them. But how much force does the police need to use? Sometimes a person just asks the police a question, and they still get arrested or beaten. Or people who are already on the ground, kneeling, subdued, they still get beaten. Peter doesn't respond. Then they argue, openly argue for the first time, about one of the protesters' main demands, something the government refused to budge on-- to start an independent investigation into police behavior.
乔纳森说，好的，是的，逮捕他们。但警察需要使用多少武力？有时一个人只是问警察一个问题，他们仍然被逮捕或殴打。或者已经倒在地上、跪着、被制服的人，他们仍然被殴打。彼得没有回应。然后他们争论，第一次公开争论，关于抗议者的主要要求之一，政府拒绝让步的事情——对抗议者行为进行独立调查。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Peter keeps repeating the same thing over and over, like he's been backed into a corner, that there's no need for an independent investigation. Now is not the right time.
彼得一遍又一遍地重复同样的事情，好像他被逼到了角落里，没有必要进行独立调查。现在不是合适的时机。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
The city already has a system in place to investigate complaints about the police.
城市已经有一个制度来调查对警察的投诉。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
They talk a little longer, but it doesn't go anywhere. Alva tells me later she had other things she could have brought up, but decided against it. She didn't want her husband to feel trapped. The word she used was [CHINESE], which translates as, dead corner. No place to go.
他们谈了一会儿，但没有任何结果。阿尔瓦后来告诉我，她还有其他可以提出的事情，但决定不提了。她不想让她丈夫感到被困住。她用的词是“死局”，没有去处。
Preserving the family was more important to her than trying to win an argument. Later, Jonathan told me he still loves his dad, but he's given up hope that his father could be a reasonable human being, at least when it comes to the police.
维护家庭对她来说比试图赢得一场争论更重要。后来，乔纳森告诉我他仍然爱他的父亲，但他已经放弃了他父亲可能是一个理智的人的希望，至少在警察方面是这样。
When I started this, I was kind of naive. I thought maybe Jonathan and his mother and father, people who actually want to understand each other, could talk about this in a productive manner. And that if they could, maybe there was hope that the rest of us could. But now, I don't have a lot of hope.
当我开始做这个时，我有点天真。我以为也许乔纳森和他的母亲和父亲，真正想互相理解的人，可以以富有成效的方式谈论这个问题。如果他们能，也许剩下的我们还有希望。但现在，我没有多少希望。
Alan Yu. He's normally a reporter for WHYY's show The Pulse.
尤阿兰。他通常是WHYY节目《脉搏》的记者。
Act Five, A Slow Boat to China. So what about all the people living in Hong Kong who have no problem with China, who like China? There's a lot of them, and they hold their own demonstrations, which are pretty small-- flag parties where flash mobs show up at malls and wave Chinese flags and sing the Chinese national anthem.
第五幕：慢船去中国。那么香港所有对中国没意见，喜欢中国的人呢？他们有很多，他们举行自己的示威活动，规模很小——国旗派对，闪电集会出现在商场，挥舞中国国旗，唱中国国歌。
And the big day to celebrate China normally would be October 1, National Day, the anniversary of the Communist Party founding the modern Chinese state. And this year was going to be a big one. It was the 70th anniversary.
而通常庆祝中国的大日子是10月1日，国庆节，中国共产党建立现代中国国家的周年纪念日。今年将是一个大日子。这是70周年纪念。
And the people who support mainland China were kind of resentful, because this day was supposed to be this huge holiday for them, but anticipating massive protests, the city shut down. Fireworks were canceled. Trains weren't running. Almost all the malls were going to be closed. The protesters had ruined the day again.
而那些支持中国大陆的人有点怨恨，因为这一天本应该是属于他们的盛大节日，但预计会有大规模抗议，城市关闭了。烟花被取消了。火车没有运行。几乎所有的商场都将关闭。抗议者又毁了这一天。
So in defiance, the pro-China people organized an anthem singing party for the morning of the first. Our co-worker, Diane Wu, went.
所以为了反抗，亲中人士组织了一场10月1日上午的赞歌演唱派对。我们的同事戴安·吴去了。
The party took place at 8:30 in the morning on a boat. Not just any boat-- on the Star Ferry, this iconic Hong Kong commuter sightseeing boat on the harbor. The ferries are these beautiful old boats from colonial times with names like Silver Star, Northern Star, Twinkling Star. And today, one of them is going to get completely covered with bright red Chinese flags.
派对在早上8:30在船上举行。不仅仅是任何船——在天星小轮上，这是香港标志性的通勤观光船，在港口上行驶。小轮是这些美丽的古老殖民时代的船，名字如银星、北星、闪烁星。今天，其中一艘将完全被鲜红的中国国旗覆盖。
A couple dozen people are gathering at the ferry terminal. They're mostly strangers, know each other loosely from previous flash mobs and get-togethers.
几十个人聚集在轮渡码头。他们大多是陌生人，从之前的闪电集会和聚会中大致相识。
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
（中文喊话）
"I love China," they shout.
“我爱中国，”他们喊道。
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
（中文喊话）
"Support the police."
“支持警察。”
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
（中文喊话）
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
It's kind of funny when you think about it, all these people up so early on their day off, getting on a boat to sing the national anthem together. It's also a little dark, because there's a real threat of violence against people who don't support the protest.
想想看，所有这些人在休假日这么早起床，上船一起唱国歌，其实有点好笑。这也有一点黑暗，因为对那些不支持抗议的人存在真正的暴力威胁。
One of these flag parties two weeks ago at a mall devolved into a brawl when protesters showed up. People on both sides got beat up. And so going out on a ferry to shout pro-China slogans is strategic. Once you're on the boat out at sea, you ought to be safe from a counter-protest. As one guy put it--
两周前在商场举行的这些国旗派对中的一个，在抗议者出现时演变成了一场斗殴。双方的人都受到了殴打。所以坐渡轮去喊亲中口号是战略性的。一旦你在海上的船上，你应该就安全了，免受反抗议。正如一个人所说——
Well, we've been living in terror for the last three months because the people on the other side, the rioters, they're really good at the terrorizing tactics. They make you feel that you should be afraid of speaking up and speaking out against them because they're so organized.
好吧，过去三个月我们生活在恐怖中，因为另一边的人，那些暴徒，他们非常擅长恐怖战术。他们让你觉得你应该害怕大声疾呼，害怕反对他们，因为他们组织得太好了。
In the terminal, everyone gathers in a semicircle, holding special holiday issues of the China Daily and singing the Chinese national anthem together.
在码头上，每个人聚成半圆，拿着《中国日报》的特别节日版，一起唱中国国歌。
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
（中文歌唱）
It's a little shaky. The guy leading it told me he just learned the words a couple of weeks ago. Most of the people here, best as I can tell, are not mainlanders who grew up with the anthem. The ones I talked to were all from Hong Kong. Being this into China is new for them, something that only happened when the protests got bad enough that they found themselves rallying around this new flag.
有点抖。带领的人告诉我他两周前才学会歌词。这里大多数人，据我所知，不是从小唱国歌长大的大陆人。我交谈过的所有人都是香港人。如此迷恋中国对他们来说是新鲜事，只有在抗议活动变得足够糟糕，他们发现自己集结在这一新旗帜周围时才发生。
And it's not always comfortable. I'm getting on the boat with Daniel, the guy who was griping about being terrorized, when someone puts a heart-shaped sticker on him.
而且并不总是舒服的。当有人给丹尼尔贴上一颗心形贴纸时，我正和那个人一起上船，那个抱怨被恐吓的人。
You just got a Chinese flag sticker stuck on you.
你刚被贴上了一张中国国旗贴纸。
Yes, yeah. I feel a little cringey about this.
是的，是的。我对此感觉有点尴尬。
Why?
为什么？
I'm not exactly that red. Compared to a lot of people here, I'm not the most red person.
我没那么红。相比这里的很多人，我不是最红的那个人。
Red, in the crayon box of the Hong Kong protests, refers to being pro-China, versus blue for the government and yellow for the protesters. Daniel almost didn't come this morning, actually. It's not really his scene. He sees being this patriotic about China as kind of dorky. Moreover--
红，在香港抗议的蜡笔盒里，指亲中，对比蓝色的政府和黄色的抗议者。事实上，丹尼尔今早差点没来。这真的不是他的场景。他认为对中国如此爱国有点书呆子气。此外——
I always tell my friends I would never want to live in China, because there's a lot of things in China that I can't accept if I were to be forced to live in China.
我总是告诉朋友，我永远不想住在中国，因为如果被迫住在中国，有些事情我无法接受。
The two things he can't accept that we end up talking about are the lack of free speech and censored access to the internet.
我们最终谈到的两件他无法接受的事情是缺乏言论自由和对互联网的审查访问。
But the truth is, I live in Hong Kong and I get to retain my almost unchecked freedom for 28 more years. And it's such a sweetheart deal for Hong Kong people.
但事实是，我住在香港，我还能再保留28年几乎不受限制的自由。这对香港人来说是一笔太甜蜜的交易。
I pointed out to him that after 28 years, it's very possible those freedoms would disappear. And he had the same response that I heard from other people who don't like the protests. He was like, well, sure, maybe.
我向他指出，28年后，那些自由很有可能消失。他也有和我不喜欢的抗议活动的其他人的同样的反应。他就像，嗯，当然，也许吧。
Well, I guess, you're talking me to appreciate the young people's perspectives. But in exchange for the freedom that they fight for, they're wreaking havoc, and they're destroying law and order.
嗯，我猜，你在说服我欣赏年轻人的视角。但在他们争取的自由的交换中，他们正在造成严重破坏，正在摧毁法律和秩序。
So in the balance, it's not worth it to you.
所以权衡之下，对你来说不值得。
If I were to choose between this, if China say, in order to have law and order, I will need to sacrifice the freedom the same way Chinese people have in Hong Kong, I would accept that balance. This is unacceptable, the whole unorganized chaos, revolution, and the havoc they wrought in Hong Kong. It's completely unacceptable. I will give up the freedom the way they do in China to stop this.
如果我必须在这两者之间做出选择，如果中国说，为了有法律和秩序，我将需要像中国人民在香港那样牺牲自由，我会接受那种平衡。这不可接受，整个无组织的混乱、革命和他们在香港造成的严重破坏。这完全不可接受。我会放弃像中国那样的自由来阻止这一切。
It's a big jump from I could never live in China to I would sacrifice my freedom just to get this to stop. But the intensity of the protests and his frustration with what he is experiencing in the city have driven him to at least try on this extreme idea.
从我永远不能住在中国到我会牺牲我的自由只是为了让这一切停止，这是一个巨大的跳跃。但抗议活动的激烈程度以及他对在城市中所经历的事情的挫败感驱使他至少尝试这种极端的想法。
Daniel's 40, works in finance. He lived in the US for 12 years. He's a football fan. Roots for the Chicago Bears because he likes the tenacious defense. He says he wasn't politically involved before all this. Went to one of the big peaceful protests last spring, more to watch than to participate.
丹尼尔40岁，从事金融工作。他在美国住了12年。他是一个足球迷。支持芝加哥熊队，因为他喜欢他们顽强的防守。他说在这一切之前他没有参与政治。去年春天参加了一次大型和平抗议，更多是为了看而不是参与。
But that changed one day when he was watching a livestream of the young protesters storming the legislative council. He was surprised how ferocious they seemed, how even the police officers looked a little scared.
但有一天，当他观看年轻抗议者冲进立法会的直播时，情况改变了。他惊讶地发现他们看起来是多么凶猛，甚至连警察看起来都有点害怕。
At that moment, I suddenly realized, oh, we're actually very close to a revolution. It could happen. It just never occurred to me that Hong Kong would go through that. It's both stunned and anxiety about unknown. Anxiety-- things can change abruptly. If there isn't a revolution, it's going to force the hand of the Chinese government to crack down on it violently.
那一刻，我突然意识到，噢，我们其实非常接近一场革命。它可能会发生。只是没想到香港会经历那种事。既震惊又对未知感到焦虑。焦虑——事情会突然改变。如果没有革命，它将迫使中国政府暴力镇压它。
And anything can happen. I could lose all the privilege I have as a Hong Kong citizen-- protection of common law, freedom of speech, but also freedom of speech protected by common law. Nobody in China enjoy this freedom, but-- if it gets to a certain point, we can lose all of these privileges, which I treasure.
什么都可能发生。我可能会失去作为香港公民拥有的所有特权——普通法的保护、言论自由，以及普通法保护的言论自由。在中国没有人享受这种自由，但是——如果到了某种程度，我们可能会失去我所珍视的所有这些特权。
He woke up the next morning to see that the coverage was wall-to-wall about police brutality. To Daniel, it seemed like everyone was leaving out the fact that the protesters had started it, which seemed deeply unjust to the police.
他第二天早上醒来看到报道铺天盖地全是关于警察暴力。对丹尼尔来说，似乎每个人都忽略了抗议者先动手的事实，这对警察来说显得非常不公正。
And that's when I started turning blue. When I felt that the police were smeared unfairly, I took my side. I chose to be on the police's side.
就在那时我开始变蓝。当我感到警察被不公平地抹黑时，我站在了这边。我选择了站在警察这边。
Other people sided against the protest for different reasons. A big one I heard was the disruption they caused. The security guard told me he had to transfer four times to get home by night because of subway shutdowns.
其他人因各种原因反对抗议。我听到的一个很大原因是他们造成的干扰。保安告诉我，因为地铁关闭，他晚上不得不转车四次才能回家。
A woman trying to get cash out of an ATM that had been destroyed by protesters said, if you're mad at the government, take it out on the government. You're only hurting people like me. A man said to me, sadly, Hong Kong is our home. Why are they destroying it?
一个试图从被抗议者摧毁的自动取款机里取钱的妇女说，如果你对政府不满，就把气发在政府身上。你只是在伤害像我这样的人。一个男人难过地对我说，香港是我们的家。为什么他们要摧毁它？
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
（中文歌唱）
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
The crowd on the boat finishes belting out the national anthem a second time, when, suddenly, everyone rushes to the railing.
船上的人群第二次唱完国歌，突然，所有人都冲向栏杆。
Everyone's waving at the sea police. They all ran to one side of the boat. It feels like it might tip over.
每个人都在向海上警察挥手。他们全都跑向船的一侧。感觉船快要倾覆了。
Everyone crammed together on one side in a position that's a little precarious. That's kind of like Daniel's world right now. He felt pushed to choose a team. Like it or not, these are his new people. He doesn't think like them, exactly. But he feels more aligned with these Chinese nationalists on this boat waving at the police than with the angry protesters ganging up on them, even if those protesters ultimately want the same thing he does-- to preserve their freedoms in Hong Kong.
每个人都挤在船的一侧，姿势有点不稳定。这就像丹尼尔现在的世界。他感到被推着选择一个团队。不管喜不喜欢，这些人是他的新伙伴。他想得不完全像他们。但他觉得与这艘船上挥舞国旗的中国民族主义者相比，与那些围攻他们的愤怒抗议者更一致，即使那些抗议者最终想要的东西和他一样——保护他们在香港的自由。
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
（中文歌唱）
Sitting on the upper deck of the Star Ferry, this was actually the first time Daniel had ever sung the national anthem in public. He told me later, as he sang, he was surprised to find that he felt something.
坐在天星小轮的上层甲板上，这实际上是丹尼尔第一次在公共场合唱国歌。他后来告诉我，当他唱的时候，他惊讶地发现他感受到了什么。
Diane Wu is the managing editor of our show, and she also has one more story for us. I'm going to set this up. It is Act Six of our show. Act Six, Two Weeks Later.
戴安·吴是我们节目的执行编辑，她还有另一个故事要给我们。我来设置一下。这是节目的第六幕。第六幕：两周后。
So October 1 wasn't just a big day for supporters of mainland China. If anything, I think it was even more anticipated by pro-democracy protesters. They knew China did not want to be embarrassed by demonstrations in Hong Kong on that day, such a big anniversary. And in the weeks leading up to it, several of them told us that they were worried. What kind of crackdown was going to come on October 1, or maybe in the days before it? Would the government try to shut them down?
所以10月1日不仅是中国大陆支持者的大日子。如果有的话，我觉得民主抗议者对此更为期待。他们知道中国在那一天，这样一个重要的周年纪念日，不想因为香港的示威而感到尴尬。而在那之前的几周里，他们中的几个人告诉我们他们很担心。10月1日或可能在那之前几天会发生什么样的镇压？政府会试图阻止他们吗？
And sure enough, the weekend before October 1, there were tons of police, undercover cops posing as protesters, surge in arrests. And on October 1, something happened that several of our interviewees predicted. For the first time, a protester was shot with a real bullet-- a teenager.
果不其然，10月1日之前的那个周末，有大量的警察，冒充抗议者的便衣警察，逮捕人数激增。而在10月1日，我们受访者预料到的一些事情发生了。第一次，一名抗议者被实弹射中——一个少年。
In the days after that, things descended. The government banned wearing face masks in public, which caused a huge backlash in the streets. Another teenager, a 14-year-old, was shot by police. Both teenagers survived, by the way. A protester slashed an officer's neck with a box cutter. A bomb went off next to a police car.
在那之后的几天里，事情陷入了低谷。政府禁止在公共场合戴口罩，这在街头引起了巨大的反弹。另一个少年，一个14岁的孩子，被警察射中。顺便说一下，两个少年都活了下来。一名抗议者用美工刀割伤了一名警察的脖子。警车旁发生了一起炸弹爆炸。
Jennifer, the protester that I went to the demonstration with in mid-September, she went to all those protests in the days before October 1, and then she was out on October 1, that big violent day. And Diane caught up with her the day after that, October 2, to see how she was doing, and to see what she made of it all.
珍妮弗，我九月中旬一起参加示威的抗议者，她参加了10月1日前几天的所有那些抗议，然后在10月1日，那个大型暴力日子她也出去了。戴安在第二天，10月2日赶上她，看看她怎么样，以及她对这一切有什么看法。
I met up with Jennifer at the MTR station in Tsuen Wan on a Wednesday. She'd taken the MTR only because she was in a big rush to meet me after work.
我周三在荃湾的MTR站见到珍妮弗。她坐MTR只是因为下班后赶时间见我。
You had a long day?
你度过了漫长的一天吗？
Yeah, very long one. It is a really sad thing, after yesterday.
是的，非常漫长。昨天之后，这真是一件令人难过的事情。
She's talking about the protester who was shot. It actually happened just a short walk from where we're standing. The last few days of protests had been especially bad. Jennifer was in the middle of the crowd when dozens of special tactics police officers exploded out of a hidden door, sprinting after protesters and tackling them to the ground. People hadn't seen this before. It caused a wave of panic. Everyone fled in terror, including Jennifer.
她说的是那个被射中的抗议者。这实际上就发生在我们站的地方几步路远的地方。过去几天的抗议特别糟糕。珍妮弗在人群中，当时几十名特殊战术警察从一扇隐藏的门中涌出，冲向抗议者并将他们扑倒在地上。人们以前没见过这个。它引起了一阵恐慌。每个人都惊恐地逃跑，包括珍妮弗。
Her phone was flooded with images of arrested protesters, pinned on the ground by riot police, face down with their wrists tied behind them. Later, she met her friend, the one who went to the protest with Ira and her, and found out that in the rush, she had gotten trapped. She came really close to getting arrested.
她的手机里充斥着被捕抗议者的照片，被防暴警察压在地上，面朝下，手腕被反绑在背后。后来，她见了她的朋友，那个和艾拉以及她一起去抗议的人，发现她在匆忙中被困住了。她差一点就被逮捕了。
All of a sudden, everything was so close to me. A very important friend of mine nearly getting arrested, and all the pictures and footages I could see after the day. Everything just was so-- was just too much for me.
突然之间，一切离我这么近。我的一位非常重要的朋友差点被捕，我在那天后看到的所有的图片和视频。一切都太……太令我承受不了了。
Yeah, it was too close.
是的，太接近了。
Yeah.
是的。
Jennifer's deeply fearful of getting arrested. Remember, it could mean years in prison. After all of that, on October 1, she was almost too scared to go protest, but braved it anyways. Then, police started to fire tear gas at people up ahead of them.
珍妮弗非常害怕被捕。记住，那可能意味着几年监狱。在所有这一切之后，10月1日那天，她差点太害怕而不敢去抗议，但还是勇敢地去了。然后，警察开始向他们前面的人发射催泪瓦斯。
We were on our way walking from Tsuen Wan to Kwai Fong. And I realized that I couldn't keep walking. I started to realize that I just feel different. Two weeks ago, when I was with Ira, I could still feel it is safe to run. I'm going to be fine. And I could still like run without any hesitation. But yesterday, I just feel like I was so terrified. I started to shake from the inside. And then I didn't know what to do.
我们正走在从荃湾去葵芳的路上。我意识到我无法再继续走下去了。我开始意识到我感觉不同了。两周前，当我和艾拉在一起时，我仍然觉得跑起来很安全。我会没事的。而且我仍然可以不假思索地奔跑。但昨天，我只是觉得我太恐惧了。我开始从心里发抖。然后我不知道该怎么办。
She panicked, started crying. Her boyfriend helped her get home.
她惊慌失措，开始哭泣。她的男朋友帮她回了家。
So I had to leave yesterday. But then, actually on my way home, there was a friend of mine. I think he was just joking and saying, you left your teammate behind. He sent this to me.
所以我昨天不得不离开。但后来，其实在我回家的路上，有一位我的朋友。我想他只是在开玩笑，说，你把队友丢在后面了。他发了这个给我。
Yeah, so I was immediately crying. I cried out immediately and really could not control myself because I didn't want this. I don't want to leave my teammates behind. I don't want to leave anyone behind. But I don't want to be a burden. And then all of a sudden, yesterday, I couldn't do anything at all.
是的，所以我立刻哭了。我立刻哭了出来，真的无法控制自己，因为我不想要这样。我不想把我的队友丢在后面。我不想把任何人丢在后面。但我不想要成为负担。然后突然之间，昨天，我什么都做不了。
The police strategy of clamping down on the protests by outlawing almost all of them, then flooding the streets with riot police and arresting tons of people, this is the toll it's taking. And of course, this is one way the whole thing could end. Maybe it'll scare people off.
警察通过取缔几乎所有抗议活动，然后用防暴警察淹没街道并逮捕大量人员来打压抗议活动的策略，这就是它造成的损失。当然，这是整件事可能结束的一种方式。也许它会吓跑人们。
Oh, I saw my boyfriend.
哦，我看到我男朋友了。
Jennifer's boyfriend, Joe, shows up. He's got his shirt tucked in, a new protest tactic from this weekend. The idea is to try and expose undercover police who wouldn't be able to tuck their shirts in over their guns and batons. Joe's here for moral support because, incredibly, Jennifer is now on her way to another protest. We're headed to a soccer stadium across the street from where the protester was shot. Jennifer figures she'll stay as long as she can tolerate.
珍妮弗的男朋友，乔，出现了。他把衬衫掖在裤子里，这是这个周末的一种新抗议策略。想法是试着暴露便衣警察，他们无法将衬衫掖在枪支和警棍上。乔来这里是为了精神支持，因为，令人难以置信的是，珍妮弗现在正在去参加另一场抗议的路上。我们正前往足球场，就在那个抗议者被射中的街对面。珍妮弗认为她会待到她能忍受为止。
We walk onto the field. It's a big solemn group of people in their work and school clothes, all facing the bleachers.
我们走进场地。这是一大群穿着工作服和校服的人，庄严地面对着看台。
There are a lot of people. Not sure where they are looking at, but I think they are just waiting for a moment to mourn.
这里有很多人。不确定他们在看着哪里，但我认为他们只是在等待一个时刻去哀悼。
It's a kind of vigil for the protester in the hospital. Jennifer and Joe put on black surgical masks.
这是一种为在医院里的抗议者举行的守夜活动。珍妮弗和乔戴上了黑色医用口罩。
Everyone has their phones up with their lights on.
每个人都举着手机，灯光亮着。
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
（中文歌唱）
We go into the streets, Jennifer's on edge. Every time she hears a loud noise, she squeezes Joe's hand. She'll stay out until 10:30. Then she'll get dinner, go home, go to bed. In the morning, Jennifer will be at work again, at her job where she can't let her bosses know where she was the night before.
我们走上街头，珍妮弗处于边缘。每当她听到巨大的声音，她就紧握乔的手。她会待到10:30。然后她会吃晚饭，回家，上床睡觉。第二天早上，珍妮弗又会去工作，在她那个不能让老板知道她前一天晚上在哪里工作的地方。
Overnight, the road cleaners will come out with backhoes to clear the barricades. They'll paint over the graffiti, fix the smashed street lights, tidy up the piles of bricks in the gutters, erasing their protests as they have so many days before, turning the city back to normal, except, of course, it can't be normal again.
夜间，筑路工人会带着挖掘机出来清理路障。他们会漆掉涂鸦，修理砸碎的路灯，清理排水沟里的一堆砖头，像之前许多天一样抹掉他们的抗议，把城市恢复正常，除非，当然，它再也不能恢复正常了。
Diane Wu.
戴安·吴。
Our program was produced today by Emanuele Berry and Diane Wu. Our brilliant field producer in Hong Kong was Yannie Chan. Thanks to our interpreters, Flora Chung, Diana Chan, and Dominic Yang.
我们的节目今天由埃曼纽尔·贝里和戴安·吴制作。我们在香港的杰出实地制片人是Yannie Chan。感谢我们的口译员Flora Chung、Diana Chan和Dominic Yang。
The people who put together our show today includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala.
今天为我们节目做出贡献的人包括Elna Baker、Susan Burton、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Damien Grave、Michelle Harris、Jessica Lussenhop、Miki Meek、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Ben Phelan、Nadia Reiman、Robyn Semien、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala。
Our executive producer is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Dave Hill for the cover of the theme of the cops show, Armed Reaction. And special thanks to Laurel Chor, Karen Cheung, Noble Wong, Yu, Tse Sai Pei, Alanna Thiede, Jiayang Fan, and Martin Lee.
我们的执行制片人是David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢Dave Hill为警匪剧《陀枪师姐》主题曲的封面制作。特别感谢Laurel Chor、Karen Cheung、Noble Wong、Yu、Tse Sai Pei、Alanna Thiede、Jiayang Fan和Martin Lee。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he'll never forget his first time on a carousel. The way he tells the story, he gets on a horse and starts to go around--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他永远不会忘记他第一次坐旋转木马。他讲述故事的方式是，他骑上一匹马，开始绕圈——
At that moment, I suddenly realized, oh, we're actually very close to a revolution. It could happen.
那一刻，我突然意识到，噢，我们其实非常接近一场革命。它可能会发生。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。